avant que la vidéo ne commence j'ai une
question à vous poser vous croyez
vraiment que les gens ont lu tous les
livres dont ils parlent bien sûr que non
sinon on ne pourrait pas parler de grand
chose
ah oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors en fait il n'y a pas un seul
secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et les
personnes les plus cultivés les profs et
les intellectuels connaissent ces cinq
secrets savez vous avez lu Ronan comme
moi mais il se garde bien d'en parler
les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer rapidement et facilement
leur culture générale parce que leur
rapport au savoir a changé et une fois
qu'ils appliquent les cinq secrets ils
comprennent toutes les références des
personnes cultivées ils savent
s'exprimer avec profondeur sur n'importe
quel sujet il brille et par leur culture
dans les conversations et dans les
débats et ils ont le recul nécessaire
pour faire preuve d'esprit critique ça
vous intéresse et bien je vous révèle
les cinq secrets et je vous explique
comment les appliquer dès aujourd'hui
pour vous cultiver dix fois plus
rapidement sans vous prendre la tête
pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de la vidéo c'est l'histoire
de 10 secondes donc faites le maintenant
et vous pourrez découvrir le le premier
secret qui vous attendra bien au chaud
dans votre boîte mail après avoir
regardé cette vidéo voilà voilà je vous
ai dit ce que je voulais vous dire bonne
vidéo
[Musique]
première référence Don Quichotte de
Miguel de Cervantes
il y a plus de 15 ans et j'ai eu une
conversation passionnante dans un hôtel
miteux ce qu'on appelle un hostel de Los
Angeles mon interlocuteur était un homme
dans la cinquantaine il portait des
lunettes et s'exprimait lentement en
choisissant ces mots avec soin
manifestement il avait beaucoup lu
notamment Platon dont il avait tiré des
leçons profondes sur la politique
lorsque je lui ai demandé quelles études
il avait faite il m'a répondu j'ai passé
plusieurs années en prison je n'avais
rien d'autre à faire que lire en effet
la prison est un contexte exceptionnel
qui favorise la méditation la lecture et
l'écriture des activités qui demandent
beaucoup de discipline et de
concentration dans un contexte normal
Miguel de Cervantes dit qu'il a eu
l'idée de son roman donne Quichotte en
prison il y a effectué plusieurs séjours
parce qu'il avait une fâcheuse tendance
à vouloir tirer un profit personnel de
sa position de fonctionnaire de la
Couronne espagnole il aurait détourné
des biens de l'Église il aurait vendu du
blé destiné à l'armée et lorsqu'il était
percepteur d'impôts il n'aurait remis
qu'une partie seulement de la somme
collectée la prison n'est qu'une des
mésaventures de Cervantes au moment où
il se met à écrire Don Quichotte sa vie
n'a été qu'une succession d'errance et
d'échecs il a été capturé par des
pirates qui l'ont gardé pendant 5 ans il
a perdu l'usage de sa main gauche à la
guerre contre les Ottomans après quoi
les gens se moquent de lui parce qu'il
est manchot il a galéré financièrement
et même connu la pauvreté il n'est pas
parvenu à vivre de sa plume et pour
couronner le tout il s'est fait prendre
pour la plupart de ses combines
mais son destin bascule à 57 ans c'est
en effet à cet âge avancé qu'il écrit un
des livres les plus importants de toute
la culture occidentale Don Quichotte est
en effet le premier roman moderne à
l'hiver 1605 au cœur de l'Empire le plus
puissant du monde qui connaît alors un
déclin économique et la stagnation
politique à cette époque des rumeurs
circulent à propos d'un livre les
librairies se retrouvent rapidement en
rupture de stock ceux qui savent lire se
prête des copies de plus en plus usés et
ceux qui ne savent pas lire se
rassemblent dans les auberges les places
de village et les tavernes pour écouter
la lecture à haute voix la toute
première édition est épuisée deux mois
seulement après la sortie
le titre complet de ce roman est
l'ingénieux Hidalgo Don Quichotte de la
Manche mais on l'abri généralement en
Dunky shot on en dit qu'il est le livre
le plus vendu de tous les temps après la
Bible ce qui fait des Cervantes un
pauvre vétéran de guerre du début du 17e
siècle manchot presque 100 dents cet
homme qui n'a connu que l'échec devient
avec ses romans l'auteur le plus lu de
toute l'histoire de l'humanité
que dire de la forme de ce roman le
livre fait en tout en comptant les deux
parties plus de 1000 pages et même
plutôt 1200 1300 dans une édition
classique sans annotation ni commentaire
donc ce n'est pas l'histoire d'un voyage
en train après la prose de Cervantes est
plutôt accessible dans les traductions
récentes les chapitres sont bref le
style est relativement simple même
direct mais d'un autre côté les
paragraphes sont parfois bien longs de
même pour les phrases qui peuvent
contenir plusieurs points-virgule le
lecteur de 2023 risque de manquer de
vocabulaire même dans les versions
modernisées les Cervantes évoque parfois
des références culturelles qui peuvent
nécessiter des allers-retours sur
Wikipédia enfin la structure innovante
du roman qui imbriquent des histoires
compliquent encore la tâche en
conclusion ce roman illisible pour un
adulte cultivé et motivé mais ça me
paraît compliqué pour un adolescent de
je vous résume rapidement l'intrigue Don
Quichotte est un pauvre espagnol de
petite noblesse liseur fanatique de
romans de chevalerie il décide de
limiter son modèle le plus grand des
chevaliers errants il s’équipe d'une
vieille armure et monte sur son maigre
cheval qu'il nomme Rossinante il prend à
son service un paysan qui monte un âne
Sancho Panza il l'a décidé à
l'accompagner en lui promettant une île
à gouverner comme les modèles de ces
romans donnent qui shot se dépassent
pour une princesse entre guillemets
nommée dulcinée qui est en réalité une
paysanne ordinaire de la région que Don
Quichotte n'a jamais rencontré
convaincu de sa mission chevaleresque
Don Quichotte décide de parcourir
l'Espagne pour combattre l'injustice ses
aventures se déroulent principalement
dans sa région d'origine située au
centre de l'Espagne au sud de Madrid la
Manche le nom complet de Don Quichotte
est d'ailleurs Donkey shot de la Manche
l'aventure la plus célèbre est racontée
dans le chapitre 8 Don Quichotte se bat
contre des géants entre guillemets qui
ne sont en réalité que des moulins avant
cet épisode a inspiré l'expression
idiomatique se battre contre des moulins
avant qui signifie lutter contre des
choses illusoires ou poursuivre un
objectif inatteignable on peut dire par
exemple essayer de réduire l'influence
des smartphones revient à se battre
contre des moulins avant
parmi les aventures emblématiques il y a
encore l’épisode de la libération des
galériens Donkey shot croise un groupe
de prisonniers enchaîné en route pour
les galères il les libère pensant qu'ils
ont été injustement punis mais les
galériens se retournent contre lui
lorsqu'il leur ordonne d'aller raconter
son acte à sa princesse imaginaire enfin
un autre épisode emblématique et celui
de la grotte de Montesinos Don Quichotte
descend dans une grotte il s'y endort et
rêve de sa princesse imaginaire cet
épisode est une allusion au motifs de la
descente aux enfers dans les récits
légendaires le héros visite le monde des
morts et il en revient transformé mur
pour la suite de ses aventures
la relation de Don Quichotte et Sancho
Panza évolue au fil de leurs aventures
leur semble association initiale de
maître et serviteurs devient une amitié
profonde cela fait qu'il s'influence
mutuellement le serviteur adopte un peu
l'idéal cheval reste de son maître
tandis que celui-ci adopte à certains
moments le pragmatisme de son serviteur
leur relation incarne la dynamique de
l'idéalisme et du réalisme
enfin comme je l'ai dit la structure du
roman est un peu compliquée les
personnages rencontrés par Don Quichotte
et Sancho Panza raconte leur propre
histoire ce qui crée un récit à
plusieurs niveaux c'était une innovation
littéraire pour l'époque autre
innovation servantès intègrement sa
propre présence dans le roman surtout
dans la seconde partie publié 10 ans
après la première servante se sert de se
procéder pour commenter son propre
travail et celui des imitateurs de la
première partie du roman cela correspond
également au thème profond du roman les
frontières de la réalité et de la
fiction
maintenant que dire concernant
l'importance et l'influence de ce roman
des livres entiers ont été écrits sur
cette question si vous voulez creuser je
vous recommande the man who in 27
fiction de William higgington qui est
prof de littérature dans une université
américaine pas loin de Washington ce
livre n'a pas été traduit en français ce
qui confirme ce que j'ai dit dans
plusieurs vidéos vous devez absolument
être capable de lire des livres en
anglais si vous voulez élargir votre
horizon intellectuelle avec tout ce
qu'Internet est plus généralement le
monde moderne a offrir comme des livres
entiers ont été écrits à propos de
l'influence de Don Quichotte dans la
culture occidentale je vais me contenter
d'évoquer les trois dimensions
essentielles de cette influence
tout d'abord avec ce roman servantès
crée une nouvelle manière de produire de
la fiction l'innovation primordiale de
cette nouvelle manière de faire c'est le
jeu subtil avec les frontières de la
réalité et de la fiction le romancier
doit permettre au lecteur de se
dissocier en deux identités d'un côté le
lecteur sait que l'histoire est inventée
mais en même temps il fait comme s'il
croyait à l'histoire le temps de la
lecture cette effets spécial sera
baptisé suspension de l'incrédulité ou
soit poétique par le poète britannique
du tournant du XIXe siècle Samuel Taylor
colridge dans son autobiographie la
suspension de l'incrédulité cela
signifie que si l'écrivain réussite à
infuser dans son œuvre un semblant de
vérité entre guillemets suffisant alors
il permet au lecteur de suspendre
momentanément son incrédulité pour
s'immerger pleinement dans le monde
fictif de l'histoire c'est notamment en
créant des personnages profonds et
nuancés ce qui distingue son roman des
oeuvres littéraires antérieures que
servantes au lecteur de s'investir
émotionnellement malgré les péripét de
l'histoire William et ginton le prof de
littérature américain que j'ai mentionné
il y a une minute William et ginton
estime que servantès a révolutionné la
fiction parce qu'il a écrit beaucoup de
pièces de théâtre avant d'écrire Donkey
shot en effet le théâtre grâce à la
représentation visuelle directe des
personnages et des décors le théâtre
facilite plus efficacement la suspension
de l'incrédulité du spectateur servant
test aurait donc importé du théâtre
l'idée qu'un personnage peut être
crédible sans être réel
la deuxième dimension de l'influence de
ce roman c'est qu'il représente une
révolution narrative autrement dit
servante crée une nouvelle manière de
raconter l'histoire il mélange
différents genres littéraires notamment
le roman de chevalerie qu'il parodie la
satyre et en même temps le roman
picaresque genre qui consiste à raconter
les aventures d'un personnage de basse
extraction le picaro se déplaçant à
travers la société et offrant un
commentaire critique sur ces différents
échelons servantes innove également sur
le plan de la narration en introduisant
la technique de la mise en abyme une
histoire dans l'Histoire et plus
généralement en remettant en question la
structure traditionnelle du récit
enfin la troisième dimension essentielle
de l’influence de ce roman et que son
protagoniste deviendra un personnage
mythique dans l'imaginaire occidentale
il symbolise la folie de l'idéalisme Don
Quichotte est d'ailleurs devenu un nom
commun en français on dit un don
Quichotte ou un Quichotte pour qualifier
une personne qui fait preuve d'un
idéalisme naïf et qui est généreuse dans
sa volonté de redresser les torts on
peut aussi dire que cette personne est
donne qui je teste Don Quichotte est
également un mythe qui symbolise
l'influence permicieuse de la fiction
comme d'autres grands auteurs de la
culture occidentale je pense notamment à
Rousseau Cervantes met en évidence le
fait que la fiction nous inspire des
désirs déraisonnables c'est pourquoi
dans l'intrigue le curé et le barbier du
village de Don Quichotte conscient de
l'origine du problème brûle ses livres
Flaubert dira la même chose sur
l'influence de la fiction mais sur un
ton sérieux dans Madame Bovary René
Girard auquel j'ai consacré mon mémoire
de philosophie à la Sorbonne René Girard
proposera une interprétation plus
précise de l'intrigue de Don Quichotte
dans mensonge romantique et vérité
romanesque pour René Girard servantès
révélerait la nature mimétique du désir
humain Don Quichotte se lance dans ses
aventures pour imiter les modèles qu'il
a découvert dans les romans de
chevalerie et en réalité nous faisons
tous la même chose mais à un degré
moindre qui ne relève pas de la folie
au-delà du roman lui-même Don Quichotte
a été repris adapté et réinterprété
depuis quatre siècles dans de nombreuses
oeuvres d'art de théâtre de musique et
de cinéma et René Girard n'est qu'un des
penseurs à avoir donné une
interprétation du sens profond du roman
pour Michel Foucault par exemple Don
Quichotte représente le moment où le
langage et les signes on cessé de
refléter la réalité autre exemple Benoît
XVI a écrit avant de devenir pape que
Don Quichotte symbolise la fin de la
mentalité du Moyen-Âge
ce qui est certain c'est qu'il fallait
un homme profondément original pour
écrire ce livre d'une profonde
originalité pour l'époque
deuxième référence les voyages de
Gulliver Jonathan Swift la spéculation
sur les crypto monnaie fait parfois
passer les casinos pour un placement de
paires de familles je connais par
exemple quelqu'un qui a eu la chance de
transformer des milliers d'euros ont des
millions en quelques jours et il existe
bien sûr des histoires dans l'autre sens
les crypto monnaie concentrent en un
laps de temps bien plus court ce qui se
produit depuis qu'il y a des bulles et
des cracks à la fin 1720 par exemple se
produit en Grande-Bretagne un des
premiers craques de l'histoire les
actions de la compagnie britannique
détentrice du monopole du commerce avec
les colonies espagnoles en Amérique les
actions de cette entreprise s'effondrent
Jonathan Swift qui est à la fois
écrivain et chef d'une cathédrale de
Dublin la capitale de l'Irlande Jonathan
Swift avait acheté les actions à leur
prix initiales près de 10 ans plus tôt
il a donc vu leur valeur gonflée jusqu'à
être multipliées par 8 puis retombées à
son niveau initial en quelques mois
c'est cette montagne russe qui aurait
inspiré à Swift l’idée du roman qu'il
écrira un an plus tard les voyages de
Gulliver pour l'expliquer plus
précisément la valeur boursière qui
gonfle et qui dégonfle rapidement aurait
inspiré à Swift l'idée d'un personnage
qui change de taille en fonction du pays
dans lequel il se rend
les voyages de Gulliver est ainsi non le
roman satirique de référence dans la
littérature mondiale il sera un modèle
pour les écrivains ultérieurs de fiction
en prose qui voudront s'adonner à la
satyre c'est-à-dire critiquer la société
en sans moquant
[Musique]
sur la forme ce n'est pas un roman
interminable il fait entre 200 et 300
pages selon les éditions comme l'indique
le titre l'histoire est subdivisée en
voyage il y en a quatre c'est lisible
même dans les premières traductions
écrit à la première personne du
singulier avec Guliver comme narrateur
ce roman favorise la connexion
émotionnelle du lecteur la lecture est
également facilité par le fait que Swift
alterne entre des phrases longues et
courtes tout comme il varie la longueur
des paragraphes le vocabulaire est
parfois désuet mais il reste dans
l'ensemble compréhensible
maintenant je vous résume rapidement
chacun des quatre voyages imaginez-vous
vous réveiller attaché au sol par des
êtres minuscules c'est ce qui arrive à
Gulliver lorsqu'il échoue sur l'île de
Lilliput les habitants eau de 15 cm le
voit donc comme un géant étant donné
cette différence Gulliver devient un
outil politique pour le roi de Lilliput
impliqué dans une guerre absurde contre
le pays voisin pourquoi absurde parce
que le motif est un désaccord sur la
façon de casser les œufs après avoir
aidé Lilliput contre ses ennemis
Gulliver fini par déplaire et doit fuir
ce premier voyage est le plus célèbre
celui qui a imprégné la culture
populaire le nom de l'île de Lilliput a
donné l'adjectif et non commun
Lilliputiens qui désigne une chose plus
souvent une personne minuscule je peux
par exemple dire que mon chihuahua est
un liliputien comparé au Labrador du
voisin deuxième voyage Gulliver arrive à
brokenag un pays de géant c'est donc lui
désormais l'être minuscule d'abord
exposé comme une curiosité il est
ensuite adopté par la reine ces géants
malgré leur taille sont doux et
bienveillants il voit la société
européenne que leur décrit Gulliver
comme violentes et corrompue le séjour
de Gulliver chez les géants prend fin
lorsqu'un aigle l'emporte
il atterrit sur une île volante Laputa
les habitants de cette île sont des
penseurs et des rêveurs obnubilé par la
musique et les mathématiques ce qui est
une référence à la philosophie très
abstraite de Platon ces gens sont-ils
vraiment si intelligents il semble
incapable de gérer les problèmes
pratiques du quotidien Gulliver visite
également le continent nommé balny
Barbie situé directement sous l'île
volante il découvre des projets
scientifiques ridicules tel celui
d'enfermer les rayons du soleil dans des
concombres
enfin lors de son dernier voyage
Gulliver découvre les houyun des chevaux
dotés de raisons et de sagesse ses
chevaux dominent des créatures
repoussant des brutales dont Gulliver
comprend qu'ils sont en réalité des
êtres humains les Yahoo c'est de là que
vient le nom de Yahoo le portail
internet populaire ou tournant des
années 2000 mais aujourd'hui largement
éclipsé par Google craignant que la
présence de Gulliver ne corrompre leur
société les chevaux intelligents lui
demandent de partir Swift dénonce par là
le manque d'empathie des personnes les
plus rationnelles Gulliver rentre donc
en Angleterre où il sera amer envers
l'humanité
comment expliquer l’influence de ce
roman dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale les voyages de Gulliver à
exercer une influence majeure à trois
niveaux il popularise le genre de la
satyre Swift critique par exemple la
futilité des motifs de guerre et plus
généralement la vanité humaine qui est
sensible au pays des géants swiftaient
inspirera d'autres auteurs à se servir
de la littérature comme outil de
commentaires sociales Voltaire et Orwell
sont parmi ces plus célèbres héritiers
deuxième niveau de l'influence de ce
livre l'image du géant chez des
créatures minuscules à intégrer
l'imaginaire collectif occidentale comme
elle est amusante elle a notamment été
reprise dans de nombreux livres pour
enfants c'est aussi la raison pour
laquelle les voyages de Gulliver est
souvent considérés à tort comme un roman
pour enfant
enfin troisième niveau de l'influence
des voyages de Gulliver ce n'est pas un
roman pour enfant parce qu'il contient
des réflexions profondes sur la
condition humaine sur le pouvoir la
morale et la place de l'homme dans
l'univers il a enrichit donc le genre
littéraire du conte philosophique comme
Montesquieu dans les Lettres persanes et
plus tard Voltaire dans Candide Swift
mise lui aussi sur le procédé narratif
consistant à comparer différents mondes
pour faire ressortir les travers de la
société européenne
troisième référence les souffrances du
jeune Werther de Goeth peu après la
publication de ce livre en 1774
plusieurs régions d'Europe l’interdisent
il ne s'agit pourtant pas d'un pamphlet
politique le thème central est l'amour
comment expliquer la censure en fait les
autorités veulent arrêter un phénomène
de contagion déclenché par le roman
beaucoup de jeunes hommes se sont mis à
imiter le héros du roman ils imitent
d'abord son style vestimentaire en
portant des vestes jaunes et des
pantalons bleus puis une partie d'entre
eux décide de pousser l'imitation
jusqu'à mettre fin à leurs jours le
suicide par pistolet devient une méthode
courante certains jeunes hommes laissent
même une copie du livre à leur côté ou
des notes faisant référence au roman le
protagoniste verter est un modèle
contagieux à l'origine d'une vague de
suicide préoccupant pour les autorités
c'est en référence à ce personnage que
les psychologues baptiseront effet
vertèrent la possible influence des
médias sur les comportements suicidaires
si les médias évoquent le suicide d'une
célébrité par exemple cela risque
d'inspirer des personnes suicidaires à
passer à l'acte elles aussi
pour faire simple ce roman est
incontournable parce qu'il est la
référence en matière de représentation
littéraire des sentiments il exprime les
tourments émotionnels de la passion
amoureuse en l'occurrence avec une
intensité et un réalisme inégalé cela a
fait du personnage de vertèbre une sorte
de miroir dans lequel des générations de
jeunes lecteurs ont vu leur propre
tourment d'où le mimétisme que j'ai
évoqué
c'est parce qu'il est la référence en
matière de représentation littéraire des
sentiments que ce roman inaugure le
mouvement littéraire allemand je tourne
un drag tempête et passion en français
qui contestent les lumières et la
suprématie de la raison cela fait de ce
roman un des textes fondateurs du
romantisme le courant culturel européen
des 18e et 19e siècle qui valorise le
sentiment en réaction contre l'esprit du
classicisme et des lumières on peut
aussi dire que les souffrances du jeune
Werther et le roman de référence dans la
littérature occidentale sur le thème du
chagrin d'amour
enfin ce livre est également important
parce que son succès dans l'Europe
entière établit d'un seul coup la gloire
de Goethe goet est le plus grand nom de
la littérature de langue allemande
puisqu'on dit de cette langue que c'est
la langue de Goethe comme on dit du
français qu'il est la langue de Molière
on peut aussi dire de Voltaire et comme
on dit de l'anglais qu'il est la langue
de Shakespeare peut-être savez-vous
aussi que l'Allemagne a installé des
instituts goethes à travers le monde
entier pour développer son soft power
c'est dire l'importance de good pour les
Allemands
que dire de la forme de ce roman avec un
peu plus de 200 pages ce n'est pas un
pavé il compile des lettres de Werther
principalement adressées à son ami et
confident Villaines il parle donc à la
première personne du singulier et il
tutoie son confident le choix par Dieu
de la forme épistolaire rend le propos
intime ce qui a l'avantage de permettre
au lecteur de se plonger directement
dans l'esprit tourmenté de vertèbres le
style est plutôt clair bien sûr la prose
paraîtra surnée un lecteur de 2023 mais
ça reste compréhensible Dieu te combine
des phrases plutôt courtes pour décrire
l'action ou de simples observations et
des phrases longues et complexes pour
exprimer des moments de passion la
taille des paragraphes varie également
enfin le vocabulaire est riche c'est
donc globalement accessible mais j'avais
trouvé la sentimentalité du style assez
lourde lorsque j'avais lu ce roman il y
a 15 ans alors que j'étais moi-même
plutôt une personne sensible
maintenant je vous résume rapidement
l'intrigue Werther un jeune artiste au
tempérament sensible et passionné
arrivent dans le paisible village de
Walheim séduit par la vie simple et
authentique des villageois il s'intègre
rapidement il croise le chemin de
Charlotte cette jeune femme belle et
douce prend soin de ses frères et sœurs
depuis le décès tragique de leur mère
touché par sa gentillesse et sa grâce
verte tombe profondément amoureux d'elle
cependant un obstacle et pas des
moindres se dresse devant lui charlotte
est déjà fiancé à Albert malgré son
amour non partagé verter qui ne pouvait
pas consulter les chaînes YouTube des
coachs en séduction Werther tente de
nouer une amitié avec le couple
Charlotte Albert mais la douleur est
trop forte il quitte donc valheim pour
Weimar où il est rejeté par
l'aristocratie locale de retour à
valrheim son chagrin s'intensifie car
charlotte est maintenant mariée à Albert
après une visite émotionnelle chez elle
vers terre décide que l'un des trois
doit mourir incapable de faire du mal à
Charlotte ou à Albert il décide donc de
se suicider il écrit une lettre d'adieu
demande les pistolets d'Albert puis se
tirent une balle il meurt seul 12 heures
plus tard et sera enterré sans cérémonie
le suicide étant un péché grave dans la
tradition chrétienne charlotte est
dévasté
les souffrances du jeune Werther est un
roman très influent dans la littérature
et plus largement dans la culture
occidentale voici les trois principales
raisons de son influence comme je l'ai
dit au début ce roman est un des textes
fondateur du romantisme got décrit la
transcendance de l'amour et la quête
d'absolu qui anime vertèrent il livre
une analyse extrêmement fine des
tourments intérieurs de son personnage
qui incarne l'idéal romantique ensuite
les souffrances du jeune Werther est
devenu un modèle de ce qu'on appelle le
roman personnel ou intime ce genre
inspiré par les Confessions de Rousseau
consiste en ce que le romancier partage
ses états d'âme à travers un personnage
qui lui ressemble beaucoup il y aura
aussi des exemples fameux en France
comme René de Chateaubriand Louis
Lambert de Balzac ou la Confession d'un
enfant du siècle de Musset
enfin le destin de Werther est devenu un
mythe dans la culture occidentale il
symbolise l'amour impossible et la
souffrance psychologique qui ont découle
les contemporains du roman ne l'ont pas
pris comme cela mais peut-être peut-on
dire avec le recul que le suicide
deverter symbolise l'échec de l'idéal
romantique en amour et plus généralement
du rapport sentimental à l'existence
quatrième référence orgueil et préjugé
Jane Austen
Edmund Wilson un critique littéraire
américain qui compte parmi les critiques
littéraires les plus importants du 20e
siècle edmun Wilson estime que seuls
deux auteurs n'ont pas été affectés par
les évolutions du goût du public depuis
le 19e siècle il y a bien sûr
Shakespeare le géant de la littérature
anglaise et Jane Austen ce roman en
particulier Orgueil et Préjugés finit
systématiquement aux premières places
dans les sondages réalisés au 20e siècle
à propos des meilleurs romans anglais sa
première édition celle de 1813 a été
épuisée en seulement un an et il n'a
jamais cessé d'être imprimé depuis
pour faire simple ce roman est
incontournable dans la littérature
occidentale parce qu'il est la référence
sur le thème du statut social il
symbolise plus précisément la rigidité
de la société bourgeoise britannique
tout particulièrement du XIXe siècle
comme le suggère le titre il offre une
critique des conventions qui
emprisonnaient les individus en
particulier les femmes dans des rôles
stéréotypés l'Autriche Jane Austen est
elle-même victime des conventions le
livre est publié anonymement parce qu'en
tant que femme de la bonne société
Austen ne peut pas revendiquer le statut
d'écrivain
sur le plan de la forme c'est un épée
roman de 500 pages le style de Jane
Austen est clair vif et ironique le
vocabulaire n'est pas compliqué tout à
fait compréhensible pour un lecteur de
2023 la lecture est d'autant plus facile
que le texte consiste essentiellement en
des dialogues il y a très peu de
description et presque aucun contexte
sociopolitique ce qui a d'ailleurs été
reproché au roman les chapitres sont
courts donc la lecture peut être
facilement morcelée de mon point de vue
le seul défaut de style et que les
phrases sont parfois longues mais bon on
attendait cela des auteurs de l'époque
je vous résume rapidement l'histoire
elle se déroule principalement dans un
comté situé à 80 km au nord de Londres
elle met en scène la famille Bennett
avec ses cinq filles dont la vive et
perspicace Elisabeth qui est la
protagoniste du roman Les Bennett
appartiennent à la classe sociale des
propriétaires de petits domaines ou de
terre à la campagne classes qu'on
appelle la petite gentry rurale Jane
trip peut être traduit par noblesse
terrienne en français les Bennett
occupent une position respectable dans
la société sans pour autant avoir le
prestige ou la richesse des grandes
familles aristocratiques
le mariage est un enjeu crucial pour
cette famille parce qu'en vertu des lois
de l'époque les filles ne peuvent pas
hériter de la propriété familiale qui
passera probablement à un cousin éloigné
à la mort des parents si les BA nets
avaient eu au moins un fils celui-ci
aurait hérité de la propriété et aurait
pu théoriquement soutenir financièrement
ses sœurs grâce aux ressources tirées de
la propriété mais comme les Bennett
n'ont que des filles celles-ci doivent
se marier afin d'assurer leur sécurité
financière personnelle
cette préoccupation se retrouve dans
l'ouverture du roman qui est une des
plus célèbres de la littérature anglaise
je cite c'est une vérité universellement
reconnue qu'un célibataire pourvu d'une
belle fortune doit être en quête d'une
épouse
l'intrigue commence en effet avec
l'arrivée de Mister Bingley se
célibataire fortuné s'installe près de
la famille d'Elizabeth MI6 Bennett voit
en lui un prétendant idéal pour l'une de
ses filles et lors d'un bal Jane l'aîné
des Bennett attire l'attention de
Bingley en parallèle Elisabeth croise le
chemin de Mr Darcy un ami de Bingley ce
Mister Darcy avec son attitude hôtel
repousse d'emblée Elizabeth ce arrogance
incarne le titre du roman
l'histoire se complique avec
l'introduction de Mister wekham un
militaire charmant mais mystérieux il
confie à Elisabeth c'est démêlé avec
Darcy ce qui entraîne la jeune femme à
se méfier encore davantage de l'homme
qu'il a marqué par son orgueil mais lors
d'une visite chez une amie Elisabeth
recroise d'Arcy et contre toute attente
il la demande en mariage mais elle
refuse elle lui reproche d'être impliqué
dans la séparation de sa soeur Jane avec
Bingley le célibataire fortuné qui est
arrivé au début de l'histoire et elle
lui reproche également son conflit avec
wicham Darcy lui écrit alors une lettre
pour se défendre dans cette lettre il
dévoile notamment la véritable nature de
William
et c'est ce personnage qui porte le
drame à sa apogée Lydia la cadette des
Bennetts s'enfuit avec William le
déshonneur menace la famille
heureusement Darcy intervient en secret
pour sauver la réputation des Bennetts
il assure le mariage de Lydia et William
ce dénouement change l'opinion
qu'Elisabeth a de Darcy lorsque leur
chemin se croise à nouveau il se marie
cette fin heureuse symbolise l'union de
deux classes sociales et la Victoire de
l'Amour sur les préjugés
que retenir de l'influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale en premier lieu Orgueil et
Préjugés est emblématique d'un
sous-genre du roman réaliste le roman de
mœurs comme le nom le suggère le roman
demeure se concentre sur les mœurs d'un
milieu social particulier Jane Austen
dépeint avec finesse et humour les
relations les mariages les
préoccupations financières et les
attentes sociales de la classe
d'Élisabeth la petite gentry rurale du
début du XIXe siècle dans cette
perspective on peut dire de ce roman
comme on dit de ceux de Balzac que c'est
de la sociologie avant l'heure
une autre dimension essentielle de
l’influence de ce livre et la libération
de la femme en effet avec son héroïne
Jane Austen donne à des générations de
lectrices un modèle de femme à l'esprit
indépendant vive et intègre l'associé
attend Elisabeth qu'elle se marie pour
la sécurité financière mais elle préfère
suivre son cœur et son jugement enfin le
roman a plus largement influencé la
culture
occidentale c'est une des histoires
emblématiques dans l'imaginaire
collectif de la question du statut
social envisagée sous l'angle de l'amour
que Jane Austen soit resté si vague sur
le contexte de son intrigue c'est
finalement révéler un avantage les
thèmes et les personnalités ont un
caractère universel grâce auquel il
continue d'intéresser les lecteurs
modernes le rendement a fait l'objet
d'innombrables adaptations et
modernisations allant des pièces de
théâtre au film et séries télévisées en
passant par les comédies musicales
l'histoire de Jane Austen a connu une
telle popularité et elle a été déclinée
sous tant de formes que certains disent
orgueil et pré jugés est une industrie
culturelle à lui seul
cinquième référence Oliver Twist Charles
Dickens
plusieurs auteurs ont remarqué que les
grandes leçons de l’œuvre de Max étaient
déjà dans la littérature de fiction du
19e siècle par exemple certains disent
que tout Marx et d'embalzac d'ailleurs
Marx émet les romans de Balzac Charles
Dickens un anglais écrit à peu près au
même moment que Balzac et le philosophe
Alain dit à propos de ce roman Oliver
Twist qui sort 30 ans avant le Capital
de Marx je cite Alain il n'y a pas tant
de différence entre ce noir tableau de
l'enfance et le tableau de l'usine par
Karl Marx à la vérité c'est dikken ce
qui influence Marx lorsque le grand
philosophe vit à Londres à partir des
années 1850 il est notamment marqué par
la terrible description que dikken se
fait de la vie de la classe ouvrière de
Manchester la ville de l'industrie du
charbon dans les temps difficiles son
roman le plus engagé
Oliver Twist ne décrit pas la condition
ouvrière mais il met en lumière la
misère qui est une conséquence de
l'industrialisation il est
incontournable dans la littérature
occidentale dans la mesure où c'est un
roman pionnier de la critique sociale à
travers ce récit Dickens montre comment
la société traite ses membres les plus
vulnérables en particulier les enfants
et le fait que le protagoniste du roman
soit un enfant jouera un rôle crucial
dans la sensibilisation du public aux
problèmes sociaux de l'époque
sur la forme l'édition complète
représente un pavé de plus de 700 pages
c'est pourquoi les éditeurs ont créé une
édition abrégée pour les jeunes lecteurs
c'est si long parce que le livre
rassemble en réalité 32 feuilletons
publiés dans une revue sur plus de deux
ans un éditeur de roman a plutôt intérêt
à réduire le nombre de pages pour
réduire ses coûts tandis qu'un éditeur
de revue a plutôt intérêt à faire durer
l'histoire concernant la prose Dickens
écrit des phrases complexes souvent
longues qui peuvent contenir plusieurs
propositions son style littéraire
produit de belles images avec une
tendance à l'hyperbole et à la satyre
mais il est compliqué pour un lecteur de
je vous résume rapidement l'histoire
Oliver né orphelin dans un hospice il a
faim en permanence et il est victime de
traitement cruel après avoir
osé demander plus de nourriture ce qui
passe pour un acte de rébellion il
devient apprenti chez un croque-mort ne
supportant pas une insulte envers sa
mère Oliver s'enfuit vers Londres là il
rencontre un pickpocket qu'il introduit
à Fagin un vieil homme à la tête d'une
bande de jeunes voleurs petite précision
le personnage de fajin a valu à Dickens
d'être accusé d'antisémitisme parce
qu'il précise que Fagin est juif et
qu'il l'appelle à de nombreuses reprises
le juif sidikken se s’est défendu en
disant que les managers depuis pocket
qu'il connaissaient étaient
effectivement Juifs le personnage de
fajin et la manière dont dikken se le
présente cela crée un archétype qui
risque malheureusement de nourrir
l'antisémitisme
je reprends l'histoire à Londres Oliver
bascule rapidement dans le monde du
crime accusé à tort de vol il est sauvé
par un témoignage et adopté par la
victime monsieur brownlo cependant en
Fagin et ses complices se créent
qu'Oliver ne les trace donc il le quitte
ensuite forcé de participer à un
cambriolage Oliver et blessé dans
l'opération il est recueilli et soigné
par les victimes qu'il voulait prévenir
une dame et sa nièce rose alors
qu'Oliver est heureux avec ces femmes
fagins aidé d'un mystérieux partenaire
dénommé monks continue de le traquer
mais Nancy une complice de fajin trahit
ce dernier en révélant à rose que monks
est le demi-frère de l'hiver et qu'il
cherche à s'emparer de son héritage
cette trahison coûtera la vie à Nancy
la vérité éclate monte le complice de
fajin et le demi-frère de l'hiver admet
avoir voulu ruiner Oliver pour garder
son héritage l'autre complice de fajin
qui a assassiné Nancy ce tu
accidentellement dans sa fuite Fagin lui
est arrêté et exécuté la paix revient au
l'hiver l'homme qu'il a adopté et les
femmes qui l'ont accueilli vivent
heureux dans un village paisible en
Angleterre
que retenir de l'influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale la dimension la plus
importante de cette influence et la
sensibilisation à la misère du siècle
Charles Dickens choisit de le faire à
travers le prisme de l'enfance parce
qu'il a lui-même passé une année
traumatisante à 12 ans en tant
qu'ouvrier dans une manufacture de
cirage son choix aura deux effets
notables comme je l'ai déjà dit les
malheurs d'un enfant sensibilise plus
efficacement le public ensuite suivre le
destin d'un enfant depuis sa naissance
impose l'idée que c'est l'influence
continue de la société et non pas le
caractère inné de l'individu qui
engendre la misère le vice et le crime
troublé par cette idée certains
critiquent malhonnêtes iront jusqu'à
reprocher radicens de faire l'apologie
de la délinquance
une autre dimension de l'influence de ce
roman et le format de feuilleton le
grand succès de liverpoolst a contribué
à légitimer ce format en même temps
qu'il a démocratisé la littérature ce
format a fait évoluer la structure
narrative vers des formes et des
techniques qui permettent de conserver
l'intérêt du lecteur tout au long de
l'histoire le romancier doit par exemple
maîtriser l'art du suspense et des
rebondissements inattendus
enfin Oliver Twist est devenu un
personnage mythique dans la culture
britannique et plus généralement
occidentale dans l'imaginaire collectif
il est l'archétype de l'enfant
vulnérable dans un monde adulte
impitoyable son histoire sera adaptée en
de nombreuses pièces de théâtre film
série télévisée et comédie musicale la
plus fameuse adaptation et la comédie
musicale du début des années 60 Oliver
avec un point d'exclamation qui est joué
à Londres puis à Broadway le célèbre
théâtre de New York avant de devenir en
1968 un film qui décrochera 6 Oscars
dont celui du meilleur film
dixième référence Crime et Châtiment
Fiodor Dostoïevski j'ai peu de temps
pour progresser en russe donc j'écoute
souvent des podcasts en promenant mon
chien hier après-midi par exemple
j'écoutais une discussion entre deux
jeunes prof de russe l'un vivant à
Saint-Pétersbourg l'autre à Barcelone il
parle de leur ville respective et à un
moment la prof établit à Barcelone
commente le climat déprimant de
Saint-Pétersbourg en disant c'est une
ville qui donne envie de tuer une
vieille dame c'est une référence à ce
roman Crime et Châtiment de Dostoïevski
il attend imprégné l'imaginaire national
russe qu'il est une référence culturelle
ordinaire dans la conversation de deux
jeunes Russes des années 2020
mais la célébrité de ce livre dépasse
largement la Russie c'est un des plus
grands romans de tous les temps il a
influencé des films américains comme
Matchpoint de Woody Allen et il est
mentionné sur les réseaux sociaux
précisément parlant il passe pour le
roman psychologique ou philosophique si
on veut le plus profond du 19e siècle
beaucoup d'écrivains dont par exemple
Freud n'abocov ou René Girard ont
analysé ce roman Jordan Peterson le
psychologue controversé qui est
actuellement l'intellectuel le plus
populaire sur internet en Occident
Jordan Peterson mentionne souvent Crime
et Châtiment
mais la gloire de ski n'est pas posthume
il a 45 ans lorsque ce roman fait de lui
un écrivain star comparé au plus grand
nom de la littérature russe les thèmes
de Crime et Châtiment agitent l'opinion
publique certes la masse des lecteurs
n'en saisit pas le message profond mais
elle aime beaucoup le mélange de romans
policiers d'histoire sentimentale et de
thèses philosophiques et qu'elle trouve
dans ce roman
[Musique]
sur la forme il y en a pour entre 500 et
700 pages selon les éditions donc ça ne
sera pas l'histoire d'une soirée au coin
du feu de soyevski a un style plutôt
clair dans les traductions françaises
avec des structures de phrases et un
vocabulaire plutôt simple en tout cas à
compréhensible pour un lecteur de 2023
après les plongées dans les dilemmes
moraux des personnages rendent le roman
pas toujours facile à lire
maintenant je vous résume rapidement
l'histoire parce que le nikov un jeune
homme pauvre de Saint-Pétersbourg et
tourmenté par une idée fixe certains
individus extraordinaires entre
guillemets peuvent se libérer de la
morale pour le bien supérieur de la
société ce persuadant qu'il appartient à
cet élite reste que le nikov Assassin's
à l'ogeuse une vieille usurière il vole
ses biens puis tue également la
demi-sœur de la logeuse lorsqu'elle
découvre le corps de celle-ci le fait
que race que le nikov soit un ancien
étudiant il a interrompu ses études
faute d'argent cela déplaît aux
étudiants russes de l’époque qui ont
l'impression d'être des pains comme des
criminels en puissance je reviens à
l'histoire rongé par la culpabilité race
colnicov joue un jeu dangereux avec le
commissaire en charge de trouver le
meurtrier leur rapport et l'avancée
progressive de l’enquête seront un des
ingrédients du succès immédiat du livre
plus que les qualités profondes qui en
feront un chef-d'œuvre de la littérature
mondiale d'ailleurs
alors que l'enquête à pense rascolnicov
rencontre une famille en difficulté dont
la fille Sonia est une jeune prostituée
les jeunes femmes réduites à la
prostitution pour survivre sont un
aspect dérangeant de la misère des
grandes villes que Dostoïevski mettent
en évidence dans ce roman cette jeune
prostituée Sonia devient un soutien
émotionnel pour Rascal nikov elle
l'encourage à trouver le réconfort dans
la foi et à se confesser
l'intrigue avance lorsqu’un homme
possédant des informations sur le crime
de Rascal nikov tente de manipuler la
situation à son avantage mais ce
potentiel délateur finit par se suicider
cet événement accentue la pression sur
rascolnikov
poussé par Sonia rascolnikov se rend
finalement à la police il est condamné à
l'exil en Sibérie Sonia le suit et reste
à ses côtés la femme russe qui
accompagne son homme Aubagne est une
image populaire souvent convoquée pour
illustrer la légendaire fidélité des
femmes russes à la fin du roman
rascolnikov trouve la rédemption grâce à
l'amour et au soutien de Sonia
comment expliquer l'importance et
l’influence de Crime et Châtiment en
premier lieu il popularise le genre du
roman psychologique
Dostoïevski y explore avec une
profondeur inégalée les méandres de
l'esprit humain plongeant dans les
tourments intérieurs de Rascal nikov
après son crime au lieu de se concentrer
principalement sur l'action extérieure
de stoïevski attire l'attention du
lecteur sur les conflits émotionnels et
la complexité des dilemmes moraux ce
choix inspirera d'autres robanciers
parmi lesquels Marcel Proust ou James
Joyce parler de la vie intérieure
présentera un avantage décisif au 20e
siècle cela permet au roman de s'adapter
à la concurrence du cinéma qui décrit
mieux les personnages et les situations
deuxième dimension de l'influence de
crime à châtiment il popularise le thème
de la critique du nihilisme qu'on peut
définir comme la doctrine d'après
laquelle il n'existe aucune vérité
morale de manière évidente l'acte de
rascolnikov et sa descente aux enfers
psychologiques montre que le nihilisme
n'est bon ni pour la société ni pour
l'individu certains disent que ce roman
est du Nietzsche avant l'heure parce
qu'il traite déjà de la révolution des
mentalités que le philosophe ramassera
dans la formule dieu est mort formule
qui signifie que le déclin des croyances
religieuses risque de faire disparaître
les valeurs de la civilisation
d'ailleurs Nietzsche découvrira
Dostoïevski sur le tard et
s'émerveillera de la proximité de leurs
idées
enfin dernière dimension essentielle de
l'influence de Crime et Châtiment il
symbolise un peu l'âme russe à travers
ce roman les Occidentaux perçoivent la
Russie comme une nation introspective
tourmentée et profondément philosophique
septième référence Guerre et Paix de
léontolstoï
j'ai lu ce roman dans une chambre
d'hôtel lors de la crise de 2008 comme
je faisais ma deuxième année d'école de
commerce à Londres j'avais dû trouver un
stage dans les environs et étant donné
le marasme économique et mon désintérêt
pour mes études je me suis contenté d'un
stage de complaisance obtenue grâce aux
propriétaires de la chambre d'étudiants
que j'avais occupé pendant ma prépa
l'entreprise où j'ai débarqué à deux
heures de train de ma colocation
londonienne n'avait absolument aucun
travail à me confier ainsi les deux
premières semaines je rentrais tôt dans
ma chambre d'hôtel et je me plongeais
dans Guerre et Paix de Tolstoï comme
Crime et Châtiment de Dostoïevski Guerre
et Paix est un des plus grands romans de
la littérature mondiale pour faire
simple c'est la plus célèbre fresque
historique du genre romanesque les
premiers chapitres parus dans la presse
avaient été critiquée mais la sortie du
livre consacrée immédiatement Tolstoï
qui était déjà un écrivain à succès elle
le consacre comme un géant de la
littérature russe les lecteurs des
valises les librairies offre le roman à
leurs amis s’écrivent d'un bout à
l'autre de la Russie pour échanger leurs
opinions sur les héros tous les
écrivains russes de l'époque ont
conscience qu'un événement de première
importance vient de se produire dans
leur univers
pour l'anecdote Tolstoï a repris le
titre d'un essai du philosophe
anarchiste français Proudhon paru
quelques années plus tôt dans cet essai
Proudhon parle du sens de la guerre pour
l'organisation sociale et Tolstoï fait
un peu la même chose mais sous la forme
d'un roman
avec deux tomes de mille pages Guerret
paix est un des plus grands romans
historique au sens propre le projet de
Tolstoï semblait si vaste et si
ambitieux lorsqu'il a commencé que sa
femme s'attendait à ce qu'il abandonne
rapidement mais il en est venu à bout en
six ans c'est si long qu'il y a
forcément des erreurs malgré les
innombrables relectures par exemple le
même médaillon est en argent dans une
scène en or dans une autre mais les
lecteurs ne s'en aperçoivent pas tant
l'art du compteur de Tolstoï est
entraînant
son style est plutôt clair il a tendance
à allonger les phrases et à sophistiquer
la structure mais elle reste
compréhensible le vocabulaire est riche
Tolstoï aime bien faire des observations
précises mais le vocabulaire n'est pas
inutilement compliqué Tolstoï adapte les
dialogues à la personnalité et à la
condition sociale des personnages il
prend le temps de décrire les paysages
les intérieurs et même les psychologies
des personnages
je vous résume maintenant l'histoire par
mesure de simplicité je sens entre mon
résumé sur le héros le plus central et
complexe du roman pierre bezoukhoff dont
l'évolution personnelle sert de fil
rouge à l'intrigue en 1805 le titre
initial du roman était d'ailleurs
l'année 1805 cette année-là la Russie
est en guerre contre la France de
Napoléon Pierre bezoukov un jeune homme
maladroit mais intelligent fait son
entrée dans la haute société de
Saint-Pétersbourg il devient l'un des
hommes les plus riches de Russie en
héritant de son père malgré cette
fortune sa vie est chaotique en
particulier il épouse une femme qui ne
l'aime pas et qui s'avère infidèle
pierre se tourne vers les francs-maçons
et tente sans succès de réformer ces
domaines pour améliorer la vie de ces
paysans c'est un thème cher à Tolstoï la
Russie signe un traité de PET temporaire
avec la France la vie de Pierre se
complique avec les rumeurs d'infidélité
de sa femme qui le pousse à un duel et à
la séparation
la guerre reprend quelques années plus
tard Pierre est pris dans la tourmente
en dépit de son manque d'expérience
militaire il finit par être capturé par
les soldats de Napoléon que Pierre
projetait d'assassiner lors de
l'invasion de Moscou cette captivité
s'avère être une période de
transformation profonde dans le camp il
rencontre un paysan simple qui lui fait
voir la vie et la foi en Dieu sous un
jour nouveau
libérer lors de la retraite française
pierre retourne en Russie il découvre
que sa femme est morte ce qui le libère
de son mariage malheureux devenu un
homme nouveau grâce aux épreuves
traversées il trouve enfin l'amour
véritable et épouse Natacha qui comme
lui a connu des épreuves dont elle est
ressortie plus forte il trouve un
bonheur simple mais profond en fondant
une famille ce qui est la vision du
bonheur de Tolstoï
le roman se conclut par une méditation
sur le rôle des individus dans le grand
cours de l'histoire la thèse de Tolstoï
est que le grand homme est une illusion
dans les faits historiques écrit-il les
soi-disant aux grands hommes ne sont que
des étiquettes qui servent à désigner
ses faits mais non pas plus de rapport
avec eux que des étiquettes images
drôles Tolstoï compare également
Napoléon à un enfant qui tient des
rubans fixés à l'intérieur d'une voiture
et qui s'imagine que c'est lui qui
conduit les chevaux
comment expliquer l'importance et
l'influence de Guerre et Paix en premier
lieu ce roman est un modèle narratif il
a établi un nouveau standard en matière
de narration épique l'approche est
multidimensionnelle Tolstoï a réussi à
intégrer des éléments historiques des
drames humains des théories
philosophiques et militaires dans une
seule œuvre tout en conservant une
cohérence et une profondeur par crainte
d'ennuyer le lecteur il a supprimé une
bonne partie des développements
théoriques mais il les a finalement
remis lors du remaniement suivant en
deuxième lieu ce roman a un intérêt
historique il a raconte les guerres
napoléoniennes du point de vue de la
Russie Tolstoï était énormément
documenté afin d'être capable de devenir
une image fidèle des événements de ma
lecture je garde notamment en souvenir
la patience et la sagesse militaire du
général russe victorieux coûteusov qui
incarne la capacité à tirer profit des
forces qui façonnent l'histoire par
opposition à Napoléon soumis à
l'illusion de la volonté individuelle
enfin Guerre et Paix renouvelle
également la tradition du roman
philosophique il sert de véhicules aux
idées philosophiques de Tolstoï qui
seront influentes en Occident au 20e
siècle l'histoire est une toile de fond
pour explorer des questions
philosophiques profondes telles que le
bien et le mal le livre arbitre et la
complexité des motivations humaines en
particulier le destin de Pierre bézukov
le héros sur lequel j'ai centré mon
résumé son destin incarne l'idée que le
mode de vie de Tolstoï un bonheur
familial en retrait de l'agitation
sociale ce mode de vie serait la
solution à la quête de sens de l'homme
spirituel qui a atteint la maturité
psychologique les digressions
philosophiques de Tolstoï seront
parodiés par Woody Allen dans un film de
1975 intitulé guerre et amour petite
interruption parce que je me dis que si
vous aimez l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée non seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en sciences
politiques en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
court de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstance vous pouvez en savoir
plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche et je pense que la
meilleure façon de vous donner une idée
du programme et d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine et qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliquée concentré
il n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à
apprendre ce travail est vraiment
formidable et passionnant Maxence mécré
directement dans les commentaires en
dessous d'une vidéo du programme la
formation est vraiment remarquable
j'étais un peu dubitatif étant donné le
prix initial mais je ne regrette pas
c'est un vrai travail de synthèse que tu
nous proposes et le format vidéo est
très adapté pour moi qui est une mémoire
essentiellement auditive le choix des
thèmes et des chapitres et pertinents et
je trouve que tu as trouvé la dose
d'approfondissement parfaite à la fois
précis mais sans fioritures vincent lui
fait carrément ma pub j'ai d'ailleurs
recommandé votre formation à ma sœur qui
travaille comme diplomate la semaine
dernière elle a déjà eu l'occasion de
mettre à profit dans ses discussions les
connaissances que vous avez diffusées
vous verrez d'autres témoignages comme
ceci dans les commentaires si vous
rejoignez le programme et si vous vous
inscrivez vous bénéficiez d'une garantie
résultat une fois que vous aurez terminé
le programme je vous rembourserai
intégralement si vous estimez que vous
n'avez pas acquis une solide culture
générale si vous voulez en savoir plus
cliquez sur le lien qui s'affiche en
haut à droite ou bien sur celui qui est
dans la description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti de ce
programme et je serai ravi qu'il en soit
de même pour vous
[Musique]
huitième référence le portrait de Dorian
Gray Oscar Wilde André Gide qui est
après Proust le deuxième géant de la
littérature française du début du 20e
siècle Jidé raconte dans ses souvenirs
d'Oscar Wilde que ce dernier lui aurait
confié avoir écrit ce roman Le Portrait
de Dorian Gray par défi en seulement
quelques jours parce qu'un de ses amis
il avait déclaré incapable d'écrire des
romans
Oscar Wilde était en effet un des
dramatures jeux les plus en vue de
Londres avant de se mettre à écrire le
portrait de Dorian Gray qui sera
effectivement son unique roman mais
cette confidence de Wild agide et
souhaite une plaisanterie soit une
légende parce que Star Wilde a en
réalité eu besoin de 9 mois pour
remettre son manuscrit à l'éditeur
le portrait de Dorian Gray est
incontournable dans la littérature
occidentale parce qu'il est le roman de
référence sur le thème de la dualité de
la personnalité il symbolise notamment
la tension entre l'apparence et la
réalité il y a l'image lisse que chacun
donne à voir aux autres et puis il y a
la réalité cachée la face sombre
derrière cette image ce que chacun est
dans son intimité la plus secrète le
portrait de Dorian Gray est également un
roman de référence sur le thème de la
corruption morale de l'élite sociale
oisive
concernant la forme il y en a pour entre
250 et 300 pages selon les éditions donc
cela se lit plutôt rapidement la pose de
Star Wars est globalement accessible
l'expression est éloquente et littéraire
par rapport à la langue ordinaire on
ressent l'élitisme artistique de
l'auteur si les phrases sont en général
plutôt longues l'habiliter de la syntaxe
et de la ponctuation permet de les
comprendre ce sont surtout les
références culturelles qui compliquent
la tâche du lecteur enfin on retrouve le
talent d'Oscar Wilde pour jouer avec les
mots cela donne des remarques
spirituelles et des formules mémorables
une des plus connues étant en jeu cite
le seul moyen de se délivrer d'une
tentation c'est 10 CD le sens de la
formule d'Oscar Wilde se manifeste à
l’extrême dans la préface du roman qui
ressemble à une compilation d'aphorisme
je passe au résumé de l'histoire Dorian
Gray est un beau jeune homme il est
peint par un artiste nommé Basile lors
de la séance d'Orient rencontre un ami
de Basile Lord Henri qui lui parle de
l'importance de la jeunesse et de la
beauté
et d'Orient exprime le souhait que ce
soit son portrait qui vieillissent à sa
place il passe sans le savoir impact
faussien d'Orient vend son âme afin de
préserver à jamais son apparence Dorian
se rapproche de l'ordre Emery l'a mis du
peintre et le peintre pressant
l'influence néfaste de Lord Henry sur
Dorian
le pouvoir malsain du portrait se révèle
plus tard d'Orient tombe amoureux d'une
actrice talentueuse nommée sibile tout
change lorsque celle-ci est perduement
amoureuse joue mal lors d'une
représentation d'Orient la rejette
cruellement hors de retour chez lui il
remarque que son portrait a changé il
affiche désormais une expression
méprisante le lendemain d'Orient se sent
coupable et veut se réconcilier avec
Sybille mais leur Henry l'a mis du
peintre l'homme qui a une influence
néfaste sur Dorian lors d'un repprant à
Dorian que l'actrice Sibylle s'est
suicidé Dorian est d'abord perturbé puis
Henry le persuade devoir ce drame comme
une oeuvre d'art Dorian accepte cette
perspective immorale et remarque que son
portrait porte désormais la culpabilité
à sa place
les années passent sans affecter la
jeunesse et la beauté de Dorian qui est
populaire dans les milieux mondains en
revanche son portrait est de plus en
plus monstrueux chaque acte immoral
commis par Dorian rend le portrait un
peu plus laid par un œillac à l'idée que
son secret puisse être découvert
d'Orient cache le portrait dans son
grenier un soir le peintre Basile rend
visite à Dorian et l’interroge à propos
des rumeurs disant qu'il mène une vie de
débauche d'Orient lui montre alors le
portrait horrifié Basile exhorte
d’orient à chercher le pardon pour ses
péchés enragé d'Orient tube Basile il
fait ensuite disparaître le corps avec
l'aide d'un chimiste qu'il fait chanter
le désir de changement de Dorian n’est
plus tard James le frère de Sybille
l'actrice qui s'est suicidé à cause de
Dorian veut venger sa sœur caché dans la
propriété de Dorian il est
accidentellement tué par un chasseur
rongé de culpabilité d'Orient décide
alors de changer ainsi il refuse de
profiter d'une jeune femme tombée
amoureuse de lui mais contrairement à
ses attentes le portrait évolue encore
en mal une expression hypocrite s’y est
ajoutée désespéré d'Orient détruit son
portrait avec le couteau qui avait servi
à tuer Basile l’auteur du portrait ses
serviteurs le retrouvent mort le couteau
planté dans la poitrine son visage
juvénile a disparu seuls les bijoux à
ses doigts permettent de l'identifier
comment expliquer l’influence de ce
roman dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale en premier lieu il est
devenu une oeuvre emblématique de ce
qu'on appelle la littérature fin de
siècle cette expression regroupe les
productions de certains auteurs du
dernier tiers du XIXe siècle influencé
par le pessimisme du philosophe
Schopenhauer il cultive un élitisme
artistique à l'écart de la société qu'il
méprise ensuite le portrait de Dorian
Gray est un des plus célèbres symboles
de la dualité humaine dans la culture
occidentale le destin du protagoniste
illustre la tension entre l'apparence
qui est le mal et la réalité qui est le
bien c'est aussi une manière de dénoncer
l'hypocrisie de la morale sociale
laquelle ne se soucie que des apparences
le succès du roman d'Oscar Wilde tient
en partie au pouvoir de fascination
universelle et intemporelle de ce thème
de la dualité humaine le personnage de
Dorian Gray est l'intrigue du roman ont
atteint un statut quasi mythique dans la
culture occidentale ils inspirent les
sciences humaines et sont régulièrement
adaptées dans la culture populaire 4
films différents dont un film d'horreur
rien que depuis les années 2000
9e référence la fin que notre hameçon
en 1929 que nous sommes est une star
internationale son 70e anniversaire et
donc célébré dans le monde entier il a
décroché le prix Nobel de littérature 9
ans plus tôt en 1920 les plus grands
noms de la littérature par exemple Franz
Kafka André Gide ou Henry Miller les
plus grands auteurs le lise et l'estime
comme un des meilleurs sinon le meilleur
auteur vivant mais voilà que notre
hameçon crame complètement sa réputation
lors de la Seconde Guerre mondiale il
fait ce que la postérité ne pourra pas
lui pardonner il soutient ouvertement
les nazis il va même bien plus loin il
rencontre personnellement Hitler en 1943
et il offre même sa médaille du prix
Nobel à Joseph Goebbels le chef de la
propagande nazi que notre hameçon est
plus qu'un simple partisan il est un
véritable fan dont l'admiration n'est
pas affecté par la tournure des
événements une semaine après la mort
d'Hitler en 1945 hamsound écrit dans le
deuxième quotidien de Norvège que le
Führer était je cite un guerrier pour
l'humanité
pas étonnant du coup que les manuels et
minimisent voire dissimule son influence
dans la littérature occidentale mais ce
roman la fin ne peut pas être oubliée
les gens qui ont entendu parler de
knuthamsun en savent d'ordinaire deux
choses il a écrit la fin et il a
rencontré Hitler pourquoi ce roman écrit
en 1890 plus de 50 ans avant la
rencontre avec le dictateur nazi est-il
incontournable parce qu'il représente la
transition entre le réalisme le modèle
dominant de la littérature du 19e siècle
et l'exploration de la subjectivité qui
est la tendance dominante de la
littérature du 20e siècle et dont le
roman emblématique est bien sûr à la
recherche du temps perdu de Proust pour
simplifier vous pouvez retenir que ce
roman représente la transition entre le
modèle d'écriture dominant de la
littérature du 19e siècle et le modèle
d'écriture dominant de la littérature du
20e siècle
concernant la forme la fin est un livre
qui fait entre 250 et 300 pages selon
les éditions il se lit plutôt facilement
la longueur des paragraphes et des
phrases varient la syntaxe et le
vocabulaire sont simples c'est un style
dépouillé qui a notamment inspiré
Hemingway le fait que Hamsun écrivait la
première personne pour raconter avec
précision ce qu'il fait et ce qu'il
ressent cela permet au lecteur de se
lier émotionnellement au narrateur en
conclusion ce roman est VRAIMENT
accessible
la seule chose qui rend la lecture
pénible c'est le sujet en effet que
notre amsoune raconte le lamentable
spectacle probablement autobiographique
d'un homme attiré par l’abîme
psychologique de la fin comme il a été
lui-même longtemps pauvre et soumis aux
privations il brosse avec la précision
de l'expérience les troubles
intellectuels et les déformations
morales qu'entraîne une inanition
prolongée
si le protagoniste a faim c'est tout
d'abord parce qu'il est pauvre il est
pris dans une course permanente à
l'argent où il ne semble jamais pouvoir
rattraper pour de bons son retard ne
tirant ces maigres revenus que des
articles pour la plupart refuser qu'il
compose pour divers journaux ainsi que
des biens qu'ils mettent engage il lui
arrive de passer jusqu'à trois jours
sans se nourrir au point où la fin
devient tyrannique le sort s'acharne sur
lui dans ces périodes critiques les
personnes susceptibles de l'aider sont
toutes absentes où il arrive toujours
trop tard les ridicules objets qu'il
propose en gage des boutons une
couverture sont tous refusés notamment
soon met en lumière le cercle vicieux de
la pauvreté le froid des nuits affaiblit
un peu plus son personnage qui n'a pas
assez d'argent pour acheter les bougies
nécessaires à la rédaction de son
article cette condition s’accompagne
toutefois d'une forme de lucidité qui
pourrait être liée à la fin le pauvre
intelligent écrit hamsoun était un
observateur bien plus fin que le riche
intelligent
mais fondamentalement la fin perturbe le
fonctionnement de l'esprit le héros de
hamsoun est particulièrement attentif
aux effets mentaux et intellectuels de
sa sous-alimentation celle-ci entraîne
tout d'abord des symptômes de surface
fatigue déprimes saute d'humeur
obsession de la nourriture nausée maux
de tête vomissements troubles du sommeil
sensation proche de l'ivresse ou profond
détachement le pauvre journaliste
remarque qu'un jeune d'une période assez
longue plusieurs jours laissent une
sorte de vide dans son cerveau c'est
alors que les symptômes deviennent
mentaux et spirituels constamment obsédé
par la nourriture le jeune homme peine à
se concentrer pour travailler j'avais le
même problème lorsque j'ai fait un jeune
de trois jours son esprit divague est
n’est plus capable que d'associer les
idées ces articles sont trop fiévreux et
violents en effet la fin décuple
légèrement de son esprit l'entraînant
par exemple dans un délire d'invention
de mots il ne parvient même plus à
effectuer des opérations mentales
basiques comme un simple calcul de
fraction pour son loyer et il commet des
erreurs grossières par exemple sur la
date d'une lettre de motivation
autre problème la fin affaiblit le sens
moral en temps normal le protagoniste
est profondément soucieux de la
dimension morale de ses actes par
exemple il tient un compte précis de ses
diverses dettes et il les règle en
priorité dès que c'est financent le lui
permettent son désir de dissimuler sa
misère le conduit même à pratiquer la
charité il sacrifie donc volontiers son
maigre confort de court terme pour venir
en aide à des individus d'un niveau de
pauvreté probablement comparable aux
siens mais la fin meta mal cette
droiture en apparence inflexible elle
soumet le héros à dintan ce changement
d'humeur le faisant passer de la
dépression à la folie il est finalement
contraint d'abandonner sa rigueur morale
la sensation de la fin est-elle qu'il en
vient à mendier à mettre en gage des
objets qui ne lui appartiennent pas la
couverture de sa logeuse et même a
demandé à inquiéter de se servir dans la
caisse pour lui faire un prêt
que retenir de l'influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale la dimension la plus
importante de cette influence est comme
je l'ai dit au début que la fin
introduit le modèle de la fiction
littéraire du 20e siècle l'écrivain
Isaac vachevi Singer qui a écrit une
préface 10 carrément que ce roman fait
de Hamsun je cite le père de l'école
moderne de la littérature l'exploration
de la subjectivité par le monologue
intérieur mais aussi le caractère
fragmentaire de la prose et l'usage des
flashbacks ces ingrédients inspireront
fortement les romanciers du 20ème siècle
une autre dimension de l'influence de ce
roman et qu'il popularise comme l'a fait
Crime et Châtiment une génération plutôt
le genre du roman psychologique hameçon
était d'ailleurs très inspiré par
Dostoïevski et on l'appelait le
dustoifski du Nord André Gide estimait
même que hamsoun était un meilleur
écrivain que de stoïevski
sur le plan culturel plus largement se
remet préfigure l'existentialisme qui
deviendra une mode intellectuelle au
début des trentes glorieuses le thème de
la fin et de ses effets psychologiques
inspirent en effet l’idée que la
condition humaine est un mélange
d'aliénation et d'absurdité on
retrouvera également cette vision de
l'existence chez Kafka
enfin ce roman a aujourd'hui dans la
culture occidentale le statut de
chef-d'oeuvre d'un auteur maudit c'est
un peu comme Voyage au bout de la nuit
de Céline mais en bien pire très
embarrassé par le nazisme de leur génie
nationale les autorités norvégiennes de
l'après-guerre prétendent qu'il est fou
et le balade d'un nazi à l'autre mais
son tout dernier livre où il raconte
cette période prouve qu'il n'était pas
fou
dixième référence
Ulysse de James Joyce
six ans après la parution de ce roman
James Joyce écrit à sa mécène une rich
héritière féministe que le 16 juin un
groupe de personnes célèbres en lui
envoyant des fleurs ce qu'ils appellent
le Bloomsday en référence au personnage
de ce roman Léopold Blum 30 ans plus
tard en 1954 un groupe d'admirateurs du
romancier fait passer la célébration au
niveau supérieur en organisant un
pèlerinage d'une journée dans Dublin la
capitale irlandaise en suivant
l'itinéraire décrit dans ce roman depuis
lors le Bloomsday est même devenu une
des plus importantes faites d'Irlandaise
chaque année le 16 juin des admirateurs
de Joyce s'habillent à la mode de son
époque et parcourt Dublin en citant des
passages de ce roman
ulysse est un roman incontournable parce
que c'est très certainement le plus
grand roman de langue anglaise du 20e
siècle il arrive souvent premier dans
les classements il est un peu à la
littérature anglophone ce qu'à la
recherche du temps perdu de Proust écrit
quelques années plus tôt et à la
littérature française c'est-à-dire le
modèle emblématique de la nouvelle
orientation du genre romanesque au 20e
siècle
[Musique]
Ulysse et bien moins long qu'à la
recherche du temps perdu mais il faudra
quand même faire un effort pour faire
partie de l'infime minorité des gens qui
l'ont lu en entier car il y en a pour
700 ou 800 pages selon les éditions et
ce n'est pas la seule difficulté en
effet
ulysse est aussi célèbre pour le fait
que c'est un des chefs-d'œuvre lit plus
difficile à lire de toute la littérature
occidentale à en croire Joyce lui-même
l'obscurité de sa prose étant parti
intentionnelle c'est un moyen de
fasciner le public j'ai inséré tellement
d'énigmes et de casse-tête dira-t-il que
cela
occupera les professeurs pendant des
siècles à débattre de ce que je voulais
dire et c'est la seule manière de
garantir l'immortalité de ce livre
concernant la forme la prose de Joyce
est bien compliqué la longueur des
phrases n'est pas problématique mais le
vocabulaire est déroutant par son
originalité et sa technicité les jeux de
mots et les références culturels
compliquent un peu plus la tâche du
lecteur si la variété des style apporte
du dynamisme elle est également
déroutante le style change à chaque
partie du livre la dernière partie du
roman et même un texte expérimental de
plusieurs dizaines de pages ce texte
n'est presque pas subdivisé en
paragraphe afin de refléter la
continuité d'un monologue intérieur
celui de la femme du protagoniste cette
original mais ce n'est pas fait pour le
plaisir de la lecture
d'un point de vue global Joyce fait
l'inverse de ce que préconise les
manuels d'écriture il cultive
l'ambiguïté en laissant la place à de
multiples interprétations il offre d'un
côté une expérience spéciale au lecteur
mais de l'autre côté il prend le risque
de le frustrer contrairement à Stendhal
qui écrivait pour être toujours lu par
les lecteurs des siècles suivants Joyce
s'est condamné à mon humble avis un être
lu que par les experts de la littérature
les plus motivés
ce livre est si compliqué qu'un
Américain un prof de l'être dans un
prestigieux lycée privé a carrément
écrit un guide pour comprendre le roman
ce guide est intitulé the guy de to
James Joyce Ulysse en français le guide
pour comprendre l'Ulysse de James Joyce
en fait
ulysse est si important dans la
littérature anglophone que ce guide
n'est pas le premier mais le plus
moderne est probablement à lire les
commentaires le meilleur
maintenant comment résumer clairement
l'intrigue du roman ce n'est pas simple
parce que justement il ne s'agit pas
d'un roman on la rangée dans cette
catégorie par commodité mais c'est un
ovni dans la littérature Joy se lui-même
a dit que c'est je cite un genre
d'encyclopédie c'est encyclopédie
compile des aventures urbaines des
dialogues intérieurs profonds des
références historiques et mythologiques
et même des exercices de style
littéraire
étant donné cette originalité je vais
vous parler des quelques aspects qui me
paraissaient essentiel pour comprendre
le contenu du livre quel est le sens du
titre tout d'abord
ulysse est un héros de la mythologie
grecque connu pour son intelligence
c'est lui qui a eu l'idée du cheval de
Troie une fois la guerre de Troie
terminée il fait un long et périlleux
voyage pour rentrer chez lui et c'est ce
que raconte l'odyssée de merde James
toys a baptisé son roman Ulysse parce
qu'il raconte la série d'aventures du
protagoniste de manière similaire au
périple du Lys dans l'épopée d'Homère à
la fin par exemple le héros de Joyce
rentre chez lui comme le héros d'Homère
rentre à Ithaque Joy se fait référence
aux aventures du héros grec et parfois
il n'est pas redit
autre aspect essentiel pour comprendre
le contenu du livre toute l'histoire se
déroule en une seule journée de 1904 le
fameux 16 juin qui est la date du Bloom
stay dont j'ai parlé au début tout c'est
clair Joyce raconte la journée ordinaire
à Dublin de deux personnages Léopold
Blum qui représente Ulysse et Stephen
dédalus et équivalent de Télémaque mais
Stephen n'est pas le fils de Léopold
comme Télémaque et le fils du Lys
Stephen est un jeune artiste et penseur
qui incarne le côté intellectuel et
spirituel de l'humanité Léopold incarne
lui le côté sensoriel et matériel de
l'humanité car il est un homme d'âge
moyen plus se terre à terre il pense à
des choses comme la nourriture le sexe
et son travail Molly Bloom la femme de
Léopold et le troisième personnage elle
représente une version moderne de
Pénélope la femme fidèle d'Ulysse
l'histoire commence à 8h du matin et
elle termine à 3 heures du matin le jour
suivant
dans le détail l'histoire est subdivisée
en 18 épisodes le jeune est Stephen et
le personnage central des trois premiers
épisodes les 12 épisodes suivants se
concentrent sur Léopold les trois
derniers épisodes racontent le retour à
la maison comme Ulysse high tech de
Léopold accompagné de Stephen les scènes
les plus emblématiques sont au début du
4e épisode la préparation du petit
déjeuner par Léopold qui apparaît comme
un homme ancré dans le quotidien ce qui
contraste fortement avec les
abstractions du reste du roman et autres
scènes emblématiques au 14ème épisode la
rencontre entre Léopold et Stephen à la
maternité moment clé à partir duquel
leur parcours fusionne
comment expliquer l'énorme influence de
ce livre
Ulysse représente tout d'abord une
révolution narrative autrement dit James
Joyce raconte une histoire comme
personne avant lui la technique
emblématique de cette révolution
narrative et le stream of contesness
courant de conscience en français il
s'agit d'une technique d'écriture qui
consiste à épouser et à refléter au plus
près les émois les pensées et les états
d'âme d'un personnage le premier auteur
à l'employé et le français Edouard
Dujardin dans sa nouvelle les lauriers
sont coupés mais c'est Joy ce qui
popularise la technique 30 ans plus tard
notamment avec le fameux monologue
intérieur de Molly Bloom à la fin du Lys
une autre raison de l’influence de ce
livre c'est qu'il repousse les limites
du roman en fait ce n'est plus un roman
au sens strict c'est-à-dire une œuvre de
fiction en prose qui raconte la destinée
d'un ou de plusieurs personnages
ulysse est bien plus que ça comme il y a
beaucoup de références culturelles
certains spécialistes de la littérature
disent que ce livre est une sorte de
texte total qui dialogue avec l'ensemble
de la tradition occidentale à cet égard
ce roman illustre la théorie de l’inter
textualité qui émergera dans les années
1960 cette théorie dit que tout texte
est lié à d'autres textes soit par des
références explicites soit par des
thèmes et des idées similaires
enfin dernière dimension essentielle de
l'influence de ce livre il est devenu un
symbole de l'Irlande un trait de
l'identité culturelle irlandaise en
effet l'intrigue est enracinée dans le
paysage et la culture de Dublin cela a
contribué à mettre cette ville et par
extension l'Irlande elle-même sur la
carte littéraire mondiale c'est assez
drôle parce que le contenu est
culturellement cosmopolite et James Joy
se lui-même était un cosmopolite qui a
vécu la majeure partie de sa vie
ailleurs en Europe il a d'ailleurs
terminé Ulysse à Paris
onzième référence Siddhartha de Herman s
timofi lyrie le psychologue de Harvard
qui est passé à la postérité comme le
grand promoteur de l'usage spirituel des
drogues dans le mouvement hippie
timophilie a dit avant votre session de
LSD lisez Siddhartha il rapproche la
lecture de ce roman de l'effet des
psychédéliques parce que lire Siddhartha
est une expérience transformatrice qui
change la conscience et la vision du
monde du lecteur
ce roman est incontournable dans la
culture occidentale parce que c'est le
roman d'apprentissage un roman
d'apprentissage est une histoire qui
suit le développement moral
psychologique ou social vers la maturité
d'un personnage principal généralement
de la jeunesse à l'âge adulte à travers
une série d'expériences et d'épreuves si
darta est le roman d'apprentissage de la
Révolution culturelle des années 1960 il
se vend déjà bien lors de sa première
publication en 1922 mais les ventes
explosent dans les années 250 parce
qu'il devient le roman initiatique culte
de la contre-culture qui émerge il passe
pour être un des livres les plus
traduits de tous les temps et plus
généralement un des plus grands succès
de l'histoire de l'édition le mouvement
hippie n'est plus une réalité
contemporaine en Occident mais si darka
continue de se vendre comme des petits
pains aux États-Unis la coutume veut
qu'on l'offre à la cérémonie de remise
de diplôme du lycée et de l'université
parce que c'est un livre qui aide à
trouver sa voie il est également
beaucoup lu par les personnes qui
connaissent une crise existentielle
une des raisons de l'extraordinaire
succès de ce roman c'est qu'il est
facile à lire tout d'abord il est court
une centaine de pages sans compter les
introductions et les préfaces ensuite la
pose de Herman s est d'une simplicité
qui rappelle la simplicité de la Bible
et plus généralement des textes
religieux qui ne peuvent pas conquérir
les masses s'ils ne sont pas claires les
phrases sont longues mais la syntaxe et
le vocabulaire ne pose aucun problème le
style a une pureté qui fait penser à la
parole d'un guide spirituel ce style est
si spécial que les lecteurs disent
qu'ils ont l'impression que le livre
leur parle
maintenant je vous résume rapidement
l'histoire le titre du roman est le nom
du héros Siddhartha qui signifie celui
qui a atteint son but c'est le même nom
que le Bouddha historique Siddhartha
Gautama mais le personnage de Herman s
est fictif il n'incarne pas le Bouddha
historique
né dans une famille aisée de Brahman la
classe sociale la plus élevée en Inde si
darta ressent le besoin de quitter son
confort familial pour chercher un sens
plus profond à la vie il quitte son
village avec son ami Govinda pour suivre
des chamanas des assets qui prônent le
renoncement au bien matériels et
émotionnels ainsi pendant trois ans si
darta et son ami pratiquent l'acétisme
mais ils comprennent que cette voie ne
leur apporte pas l'illumination qu'ils
espérait
ils entendent parler de gothama un homme
qui aurait atteint l'illumination il
quitte donc les Chama na pour rejoindre
ce nouveau guide conquis par la sagesse
de gothama Govinda décide de rester avec
lui si darta lui pense que la véritable
sagesse ne peut pas être enseignée et
choisi de continuer sa quête seul
la suite de son aventure ressemble
davantage à une vie ordinaire il tombe
amoureux d'une belle courtisane et
travaille pour un riche marchand pendant
plusieurs années il s'enrichit et ça
donne au plaisir de la vie seulement ils
se rend compte qu'il s'éloigne de sa
quête spirituelle sentant le besoin d'y
retourner il abandonne tout et par alors
même que la courtisane est enceinte de
lui il trouve refuge auprès d'un passeur
du nom de vaseux d'Eva ce personnage
permet aux gens de passer d'une rive à
l'autre du fleuve mais symboliquement il
permet à Siddhartha de passer à l'étape
suivante de sa quête spirituelle il
passe du temps au bord d'un fleuve ou
Siddhartha apprend à écouter la nature
la courtisane et leur enfant arrivent au
bord du fleuve tué par la morsure d'un
serpent la mer laisse donc Siddhartha
élever leur fils avec le passeur vasut
d'Eva au bord du fleuve inspiré par le
parcours de son père le fils s'enfuit
pour lui aussi suivre son propre chemin
le père veut d'abord retrouver son fils
puis il finit par accepter sa décision
avec séré nité le pasteur vaut des
vapeur laissant Siddhartha seule au bord
du fleuve il finit par y trouver la paix
intérieure un jour Govinda son ami
d'enfance avec lequel il a commencé son
voyage Govinda le retrouve si dartha lui
explique que la sagesse ne peut être
enseignée qu'elle doit être découverte
par soi-même en l'embrassant sur le
front Gauvin da comprend que Siddhartha
a atteint l'éveil qu'il cherchait tant
comment expliquer l'énorme influence de
ce livre sur le plan de la littérature
il renouvelle la tradition européenne du
roman d'apprentissage bien que Hermann s
choisisse pour son histoire un contexte
de loin dans l'espace et dans le temps
de l'Europe du 20e siècle si darka est
devenu un roman d'apprentissage
universel toujours apprécié par les
étudiants américains du 21e siècle du
point de vue de la culture plus
largement ce roman a été un des premiers
à introduire massivement les concepts de
la spiritualité orientale au public
occidental les gens ont cru à tort que
Herman s était lui-même bouddhiste il
était resté fidèle aux protestantisme de
ses parents et il défendait une
spiritualité universelle sans doctrine
précise
la portée philosophique de ce roman ne
se résume donc pas à la spiritualité
orientale en Occident si darka est
emblématique de la nouvelle spiritualité
critique de la société de consommation
qui émerge au cours des trentes
glorieuses et qui inspire notamment le
mouvement hippie une des
caractéristiques essentielles de cette
nouvelle spiritualité et qu'elle
individualise la quête spirituelle
c'est-à-dire que chacun doit suivre sa
propre voie et trouver ses propres
réponses alors que les grandes religions
occidentales fournissent des réponses
génériques cette spiritualité est en
partie inspirée par la psychanalyse de
Young qui est lui aussi une source du
renouveau spirituel des années 1960 non
seulement Herman s'était beaucoup
intéressé à la psychanalyse mais il
avait fait 70 séances avec un disciple
de Young quelques années avant d'écrire
Siddhartha
douzième référence le procès de Franz
Kafka fin 2020 les autorités françaises
confine le pays pour une deuxième fois
elle décide quelles activités suspendre
les examens du permis de conduire sont
maintenus les inspecteurs sont au boulot
prêts à évaluer les candidats oui mais
dans le même temps les autorités ont
fermé les auto-écoles résultat les
candidats ne peuvent pas se préparer à
l'examen qui est maintenu c'est ce qu'on
appelle une situation Kaf Cayenne
l'adjectif est revenu à la mode parce
que les Français sont sont servis pour
qualifier les dérives de
l'administration dans la gestion de la
pandémie les autos attestations ou
encore certaines règles en matière de
distanciation sociale on nourrit le
sentiment d'une absurdité bureaucratique
l'adjectif kafkaïen que beaucoup de gens
emploient jamais avoir ouvert un livre
de Kafka cet adjectif vient
principalement de ce roman Le procès il
est donc incontournable dans la culture
occidentale parce qu'il symbolise
l'absurdité de la bureaucratie c'est
certains thèmes précis mais
l'administration c'est tellement
développée en Occident depuis les
trentes glorieuses avec l'émergence de
ce qu'on appelle l'État-providence
l'administration c'est tellement
développée que l'individu occidental
ordinaire doit composer avec la
bureaucratie et parfois ces
dysfonctionnements dans son existence
quotidienne donc ce roman est une
histoire bien utile pour comprendre le
monde
il est considéré de nos jours comme le
deuxième plus important roman de langue
allemande après les souffrances du jeune
Werther de Goethe
quand dire sur la forme c'est un livre
relativement court plus ou moins 200
pages selon les éditions de prime abord
le style de Kafka est très clair dans
les phrases les propositions sont
courtes la syntaxe est élémentaire et le
vocabulaire est simple mais cette clarté
est de surface en fait la lecture n'est
pas si facile car la prose de Kafka
cultive l'ambiguïté comme aime t'a le
faire les romanciers emblématiques du
nouveau modèle d'écriture qui s'impose
au 20e siècle Kafka n'explique pas tout
clairement il laisse place à
l’interprétation enfin les paragraphes
sont parfois bien longs ce qui a pour
effet de renforcer le sentiment
d'oppression qu'inspire l'histoire
je vous la résume rapidement le héros
Joseph K et cadre dans une banque un
matin il est arrêté on ne lui dit pas
pourquoi ce détail qui est contraire au
droit à un procès équitable sera
essentiel dans la postérité du livre
bien qu'il soit arrêté Joseph K n’est
pas mis en prison il peut continuer sa
vie normalement en attendant son procès
ça le jeu se pense que son arrestation
est lié à une liaison avec sa voisine
Joseph K va rendre visite à cette
voisine et l’embrasse plus tard il
découvre qu'une autre locataire emménage
avec sa voisine et il pense qu'elle
l'accueille afin de prendre ses
distances avec lui
un dimanche Joseph K doit se présenter
devant le tribunal il trouve finalement
la salle dans un grenier il est en
retard il essaie de se défendre mais
agasses encore plus les juges Joseph
katante de parler au juge pour
comprendre son affaire il découvre
ensuite les agents qui l'ont arrêté en
train d'être fouettés il essaie de les
aider en vain
son oncle lui présente un avocat rould
mais comme Joseph K a des doutes il
consulte le peintre officiel du tribunal
selon ce dernier l'acquittement et peu
probable Joseph cas se rend chez
l'avocat afin de le renvoyer il y
rencontre un autre client un négociant
dénommé monsieur block ce monsieur
bloque lui donne des conseils alors même
qu'il a à lui tout perdu à cause de son
procès qui dure depuis plus de 5 ans et
que cette situation le place dans une
dépendance extrême par rapport à
l'avocat ensuite Joseph K accompagne un
important client devant la cathédrale de
la ville un prêtre l'interpelle il lui
compte ce qu'on appelle la parabole de
la loi dans cette parabole un homme est
le seul à attendre des années devant une
porte menant à la loi et il apprend
avant de mourir qu'il ne pourra
finalement pas y entrer cette parabole
signifie que la justice est plus
généralement l'administration sont des
systèmes fait part et pour des initiés
et qu'ils sont impénétrables pour les
hommes ordinaires
le roman finit avec l'exécution de
Joseph K deux hommes se rendent chez lui
la veille de son 31e anniversaire il
l'exécute sommairement avec un couteau
de boucher comme un chien comme un
Joseph ka avant d'expirer
[Musique]
le procès est un chef-d'oeuvre qui a
laissé une empreinte indélébile sur la
littérature et la culture occidentale et
pourtant il a été publié de manière
posthume par un ami de Kafka contre la
volonté express de Kafka qui voulait
qu'on brûle ses écrits première
dimension essentielle de l'influence de
ce roman il contribue au renouvellement
du genre Kafka hybride les conventions
narratives en optant pour une histoire
sans résolution claire et en laissant de
nombreuses questions sans réponse cela
inspirera les auteurs ultérieurs à
expérimenter avec le roman ensuite la
deuxième dimension essentielle de
l'influence du procès tient à la lecture
politique qu'on peut en faire il connaît
une véritable vogue au début des trentes
glorieuses parce que le grand public il
voit une dénonciation des bureaucraties
totalitaires policière en particulier de
l'Allemagne nazie et de l'URSS à partir
de la fin des trentes glorieuses il
symbolise plus généralement l'expansion
de la bureaucratie
enfin la troisième dimension essentielle
de l’influence de ce roman tient à la
lecture philosophique qu'on peut en
faire si le procès devient très
populaire dans l'après-guerre c'est
parce que le public cultivé voit en
Joseph K un héros existentialiste ainsi
l'idée du procès qu'on ne peut pas
gagner ne représenterait pas simplement
l'absurdité du système judiciaire de
l'administration moderne ou même de
toute structure sociale mais plus
fondamentalement l’absurdité de la
condition humaine d'après cette lecture
le héros de Kafka serait donc un
précurseur des héros de Sartre et de
Camus
13ème référence Gatsby le Magnifique
Francis Scott Fitzgerald vous avez
peut-être vu passer ce même sur internet
ou sur les réseaux sociaux Leonardo
DiCaprio en costume qui lève une coupe
de champagne avec un sourire narquois je
crois même que mon monteur l'a déjà
utilisé pour une de mes vidéos et bien
cette image virale est tirée de
l'adaptation au cinéma de ce roman vous
avez peut-être également entendu parler
plus récemment de l'émission de podcast
qui raconte le destin d'Oussama Amar la
figure emblématique du monde des
startups en France il y a même eu une
campagne de pub dont le métro parisien
cette émission a été baptisée Oussama le
magnifique en référence à ma
connaissance à ce roman
ce livre paru il y a presque 100 ans et
donc encore une référence incontournable
dans la culture occidentale en 2023
c'est un des plus grands chefs de la
littérature américaine et même de la
littérature de langue anglaise il est
d'autant plus important aux États-Unis
qu'il est un grand classique des cours
de littérature tous les Américains en
ont donc au moins entendu parler au
collège ou au lycée sur le plan des
idées Gatsby le Magnifique est une des
critiques romanesques sinon la critique
romanesque la plus célèbre de ce qu'on
appelle le rêve américain c'est-à-dire
l'idée que n'importe qui peut réussir
socialement surtout économiquement aux
États-Unis grâce à son travail acharné
et à sa détermination en critiquant le
rêve américain ce roman critique plus
fondamentalement l'idée que la réussite
sociale apporte le bonheur
pour l'anecdote ce livre est né en
France grâce au dollar fort au début des
années 1920 un dollar permet d'obtenir
beaucoup de francs ce qui veut dire
qu'en ayant des revenus en dollars et
des dépenses en franc ont décuple son
niveau de vie Fitzgerald se rend sur la
côte d'Azur pour profiter de cette
situation il écrit Gatsby le Magnifique
dans une petite ville à 60 km à l'ouest
de Nice Saint-Raphaël ou enfants j'ai
passé une partie de mes vacances chez
mes grands-parents seconde partie de
l'anecdote Fitzgerald fera lire le
manuscrit de ce roman à Hemingway à
Paris à la terrasse de la Closerie des
Lilas une brasserie huppée qui était un
repère décrivain et d'intellectuel dans
le quartier Montparnasse c'est
aujourd'hui un restaurant gastronomique
que dire de la forme de ce roman c'est
un livre d'un peu plus de 200 pages au
format poche et en enlevant les préfaces
il y en a plutôt pour 170 pages bien que
les phrases soient souvent longues la
prose de Fitzgerald est claire
l’écriture est travaillée et élégante
sans que ses qualités ne rendent la
lecture plus difficile le style est
globalement efficace les descriptions
sont peu nombreuses et subtiles les
péripéties s'enchaînent avec fluidité
je passe au résumé de l'histoire le
narrateur n'est pas Gatsby mais nique
nique est un jeune Américain privilégié
passé par la prestigieuse université
Yale il arrive à New York au printemps
1922 pour travailler dans la finance il
loue une petite maison à longue Island
la grande île située à l'est de la ville
et qui est un peu le terrain de jeu des
riches Nick et voisin d'un manoir
luxueux appartenant à Jay Gatsby un
mystérieux millionnaire qui organise des
fêtes somptueuses
un soir Annick dîner chez sa cousine
Daisy et son mari Tom qui vivent de
l'autre côté de la baie le personnage de
Tom représente la classe sociale des
héritiers tandis que le personnage de
Gatsby représente les nouveaux riches
Nick aperçoit là mais leur première
rencontre survient peu après invité à
une fête chez Gatsby Nyx se rend compte
que peu d'invités connaissent l'euro un
beau dandy qui parle avec un accent
anglais Nick remarque que sa cousine
Daisy obsède Gatsby
fin juillet Gatsby et le narrateur Nick
se revoit alors d'un déjeuner Gatsby
raconte ses exploits de guerre et ses
études à Oxford il prétend venir d'une
riche famille de San Francisco Jordan
une amie de Daisy la cousine de Nick
révèle à Nick que Gatsby et Daisy
étaient en couple avant que Gatsby ne
parte à la guerre Et maintenant qu'il
est riche et Gatsby espère reconquérir
des îles il demande donc à nid que
d'organiser une rencontre à partir de
cette rencontre Daisy et Gatsby entame
une relation
en septembre Tom le mari de Daisy
découvre qu'elle le trompe lors d'une
mise au point entre les trois
personnages Tom révèle à sa femme que
Gatsby s'est enrichi en trafiquant de
l'alcool c'était l'époque de la
prohibition aux États-Unis ce qui
détruit la réputation que Gatsby a
soigneusement construite sommet par
Gatsby de dire qu'en réalité elle n'a
jamais aimé son mari Daisy refuse et
choisit même de rester avec son mari
confiant dans le choix de sa femme Tom
autorise Gatsby à la ramener en voiture
sur le chemin Gatsby laisse Daisy
conduire afin qu'elle se calme mais elle
tue une femme qui n’est autre que la
maîtresse de son mari Tom Gatsby prend
le blâme pour protéger Daisy le mari de
la femme tuée pense que le conducteur du
véhicule est l'homme avec lequel sa
femme le trompait donc il tue Gatsby
avant de se suicider
il n'y a presque personne au funérailles
de Gatsby le narrateur se met à haïr New
York il pense que Gatsby sa cousine son
mari et lui tous originaire de la partie
centrale des États-Unis le Midwest ne
sont pas faits pour l'Est du pays il
quitte New York
comment résumer l'influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale en premier lieu comme je
l'ai dit au début Gatsby le Magnifique
incarne la critique du rêve américain
Gatsby s'est enrichi rapidement mais de
manière illégale autre dimension de la
critique Gatsby n'est pas épanoui
socialement les gens qui se rendent
assez fêtes ne sont pas de véritables
amis ils savent à peine qui il est enfin
tout son argent ne peut pas acheter ce
qui a le plus de valeur à ses yeux
l'amour de Daisy
l'influence de Gatsby le Magnifique est
tient également à son intérêt historique
Fitzgerald dépeint à travers la Jet 7
new yorkaise les denismes des années
1920 l'époque qu'on appelle les années
folles après la Première Guerre mondiale
l'Occident connait une explosion
d'énergie créative d'optimisme et la
société change vite on appelle également
cette période les années jazz parce que
la diffusion du jazz notamment grâce à
la radio la diffusion du jazz depuis les
États-Unis incarne l'énergie créative de
l'époque
enfin l'influence de Gatsby le
Magnifique tient également à son intérêt
sociologique aux États-Unis les années
1920 sont celles de l'émergence de la
société de consommation et d'un nouveau
rapport à la richesse symbolisé dans le
roman par l'opposition entre Tom
l'héritier est passé pariel et Gatsby le
nouveau riche qui s'est sali les mains
pour réaliser le rêve américain l'effet
des énormes dépensent de Gatsby illustre
le concept de la consommation
ostentatoire du sociologue américain
weblem dans le capitalisme industriel la
valeur sociale est désormais réduite à
l'argent c'est pourquoi l'élite sociale
étale sa richesse comme Gatsby pour
donner la preuve de son statut ainsi ce
roman révèle déjà la logique de la
consommation expliquée par Baudrillard
45 ans plus tard dans la société de
consommation on consomme pour exprimer
son statut
14ème référence les raisins de la colère
John Steinbeck
ce roman est le premier livre que j'ai
lu en anglais sans dictionnaire j'aurais
bien utilisé un dictionnaire mais en
fait je n'en avais pas c'était l'été de
mes 19 ans que je passais à traverser
les États-Unis en auto-stop avec mon
meilleur ami j'ai mis la main sur une
vieille édition de poche délabrée dans
une énorme librairie au Texas pour moi
d'un dollars j'ai tué beaucoup de temps
avec une histoire qui m'a impressionné
et qui m'a fait relativiser les
conditions difficiles dans lesquelles
mon ami et moi nous sommes parfois
retrouvés en effet les raisins de la
colère et le roman emblématique de la
misère sociale de la Grande Dépression
la crise économique des années 1930 qui
commence par le krach de 1929 et qui
restera la plus grave crise économique
du 20e siècle les raisins de la colère
et plus généralement un des meilleurs
romans de la littérature occidentale sur
le thème de la misère c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles John Steinbeck
remportera le prix Nobel de littérature
en 1962
concernant la forme c'est un gros livre
de plus de 600 pages après le style de
Steinbeck est simple les phrases sont
souvent courtes le vocabulaire est juste
sans être compliqué les descriptions
sont parfois un peu longues pour un
lecteur de 2023 les dialogues en argot
font très réalistes et nous plonge dans
l'identité sociale et spécifique des
personnages qui sont de pauvres fermiers
du centre des États-Unis mais je me
souviens qu'il m'avait fallu du temps
pour m'adapter au dialogue en argot en
lisant en anglais
maintenant je vous résume l'intrigue Tom
joye revient chez lui après avoir purgé
une peine de prison en route il
rencontre Jim quasi un ancien pasteur
puis il découvre que sa famille a dû
abandonner leur ferme en Oklahoma poussé
par la sécheresse et la mécanisation des
terres par les grandes propriétaires qui
sont souvent des banques la famille joyd
et l'ancien pasteur quasi prépare un
voyage vers la Californie perçu comme un
eldorado ces migrants originaires de
l'oklaoma seront appelés hokis OK
la famille joyd entame un périlleux
voyage sur la route 66 la mythique Route
américaine des grandes migrations qui
traversent le pays de Chicago au
nord-est jusqu'à la Californie au
sud-ouest les JO de côtoient d'autres
familles qui fuient la misère comme eux
l'entraide et cruciale tout au long de
la route malgré les obstacles il est
pertes en chemin les JO de continuent à
espérer une vie meilleure en Californie
mais une fois arrivé les rêves se
transforme rapidement en cauchemar
considéré comme des agitateurs et des
marginaux les jeux de sont accueillis
avec méfiance voir avec hostilité par
les habitants et les riches
propriétaires de terre les JO de sont
même considérés comme des sous-hommes il
faut dire que le flot perpétuel des
émigrants fait régner la panique dans
l'ouest la concurrence et féroce pour
des emplois mal rémunérés et les
conditions de travail sont souvent
précaires
chaque fois que les JO de troubles du
travail comme la cueillette de pêche ou
la coupure du coton l'espoir René
brièvement puis ils sont écrasés par
l'exploitation et la pauvreté les
salaires versés ne sont pas les salaires
promis et ils peuvent baisser du jour au
lendemain les tentatives de grève sont
brutalement réprimées par la police la
famille Joe de supporte sa situation
grâce à l'amour qui unissait membres ils
sont accablés par la misère mais ils
sont aussi en colère d'où le titre du
roman trouvé par la femme de Steinbeck
ce titre reprend une image de
l'Apocalypse le dernier livre de
l'Ancien Testament dans la Bible la
récolte des raisins symbolise l'idée que
les responsables de l'injustice subi par
la famille Jaude les exploiteurs vont
récolter les fruits du mal qu'ils font
la colère et la justice divine vont
s'abattre sur eux
comment résumer l'influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale la première dimension est
qu'il a développé la conscience sociale
américaine et plus généralement
occidentale Steinbeck dépend puissamment
la misère des hocquises les familles qui
s'entassent dans les camps de migrants
les journées de travail exténuantes dans
les champs pour des salaires dérisoirs
la stigmatisation sociale par les
habitants locaux et par les autorités
les conséquences de la misère sur la
santé la grand-mère de la famille Joe de
meurt au cours du voyage et une des
filles donnent naissance à un bébé
Mornet les raisins de la colère est un
peu l'épopée américaine de la misère du
coup Tom jrod et la famille Joe de
symbolise les pauvres américains dans la
culture populaire l'icône du rock
américain Bruce Springsteen intituléa
par exemple un de ses albums The Ghost
of Tom jrod le fantôme de Tom Jones en
français
une influence plus précise de ce roman
dans la culture occidentale et qu'il est
une des plus célèbres allégories de
l'immigration la famille Joe de incarne
un déplacement historiquement massif de
population à travers les États-Unis
causés par la Grande Dépression à
travers leur destin le lecteur comprend
l'expérience de quitter sa terre-Natale
sous la contrainte de la misère pour
rejoindre un eldorado fantasmé ou en
plus de retrouver la misère on
découvrira le mépris et même la
déshumanisation
enfin une autre dimension de l'influence
de ce roman dans la culture occidentale
et qu'il met en scène les mécanismes de
l'exploitation capitaliste j'avais été
frappé par le processus de recrutement
des riches propriétaires agricoles de
Californie il distribue bien plus de
prospectus qu'ils n'ont d'emploient à
offrir comme ça ils embauchent les gens
qui acceptent de travailler au salaire
les plus faibles c'est une illustration
concrète de ce que Marx appelle l'armée
de réserves la disponibilité des
prolétaires sans emploi fait pression
sur les salaires des prolétaires
employés Steinbeck montre également
comment les riches propriétaires
agricoles de Californie extorquent aux
ouvriers la valeur de leur travail en
réduisant sans cesse les salaires ou
encore en rémunérant les ouvriers
antiquaise échangeables à la boutique du
camp où les prix sont gonflés et avant
même le voyage vers la Californie
Steinbeck décrit le mécanisme implacable
de l'usure grâce auquel les banques
exproprient les naïf paysans de
l'Oklahoma vous aimez les gros manuels
c'est bien c'est pas une partie de
plaisir mais comment faire si vous
voulez découvrir les idées d'Aristote
par exemple et bien aller sur le site
1000 idées de culture générale vous
tapez Aristote dans la barre de
recherche et vous avez les synthèses des
synthèses très claires des meilleures
idées d'Aristote rédiger avec amour et
beaucoup de café par votre serviteur et
comme le nom l'indique 1000 idées de
culture générale ce n'est pas que de la
philo vous trouverez aussi des
meilleures idées en économie en
littérature en histoire en sciences
politiques en psychologie etc alors
maintenant que faire de ces gros manuels
alors moi je les garde parce qu'ils sont
bien pratiques pour remplir la
bibliothèque quand je tourne des vidéos
mais vous vous pouvez vous en servir
comme support pour poser la casserole ou
bien pour faire de la musculation si
vous n'aimez pas les haltères classiques
c'est moins fatigant que de les lire
vous n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre
la tête pour découvrir le meilleur de la
pensée allez simplement sur 1000 idées
de culture générale
15ème référence le désert des tartares
Dino Buzzati à l'élection présidentielle
de mai 1974 seul 200000 voix séparent
Valéry Giscard d'Estaing le vainqueur de
François Mitterrand moins d'un an plus
tard le journaliste Bernard Pivot invite
le perdant à apostrophe l'émission
littéraire culte de France 2 et après le
passage de Mitterrand dans l'émission
beaucoup de gens pensent la même chose
si cette émission avait eu lieu avant
l'élection présidentielle de 1974
imagine-t-il la maigre avance de Valéry
Giscard d'Estaing aurait fondu les gens
qui ont vu l'émission pensent cela parce
que François Mitterrand y a été brillant
Bernard Pivot estime qu'aucun autre
invité prestigieux dans l'histoire de
l'émission n'a réussi à commenter avec
autant de brio les livres dont il a
choisi de parler et c'est pendant les 10
dernières minutes de l'émission en
parlant de ce roman Le Désert des
Tartares de dinobozzati que Mitterrand a
été le plus éblouissant d'après Bernard
Pivot c'était je cite le silence absolu
sur le plateau
le désert des tartare de dinobuzzati est
incontournable dans la littérature
occidentale pour deux raisons tout
d'abord c'est le roman de référence sur
le thème du destin manqué c'est une
allégorie qui montre comment les hommes
espèrent souvent que des événements
extérieurs viennent donner un sens à
leur vie la seconde raison de
l'importance du Désert des Tartares et
qu'il est un des plus grands sinon le
plus grand roman italien il vaut à
boutzati d’être comparé au plus célèbre
romancier de la littérature occidentale
étant donné l'ambiance qui se dégage de
ce roman boutzati est appelé le Kafka
italien
concernant la forme c'est un livre d'un
peu moins de 300 pages comme budgeti
était journaliste son style est à la
fois simple même simpliste critique
certains le style de budzati est simple
réaliste mais en même temps poétique il
varie la longueur des phrases et des
paragraphes le vocabulaire ne pose aucun
problème
maintenant je vous résume l'histoire
Giovanni Drogo est un jeune lieutenant
affecté au fort Bastiani un poste
frontière isolé au-delà des murailles de
ce fort s’étant un désert qui donne son
titre roman Le Désert des Tartares mais
ce nom ne désigne pas précisément le
peuple d'Asie centrale les Tartares
symbolise un ennemi indéfini et
mystérieux ce nom ajoute une couche
d'exotisme et d'énigmes et renforce
ainsi l'atmosphère d'incertitude qui
imprègne toute l'histoire
fascinée par le fort Bastiani et le
paysage Drogo décide de d'y rester
malgré une première envie de partir les
mois s'étendent en année chaque jour est
rempli de l'attente d'une attaque des
ennemis du Nord qui ne vient jamais
des choses se produisent au bout de deux
ans un cheval sans cavalier déclenche
une fausse alerte un soldat du Fort est
tué un officier meurt de fatigue en
mission au bout de quatre ans Drogo
obtient une permission et retourne
brièvement en ville mais ils se sont
déconnectés de sa vie passée il revient
au fort poussé par des rumeurs
d'activités ennemies au nord mais
l'attente continue après 15 ans de
présence Drogo devient capitaine
c'est après 30 ans passés au fort que
les ennemis tant attendus se rapprochent
enfin mais Drogo est trop malade pour
participer à la bataille rapatrier vers
la ville il croise des renforts
montantes au front il termine ses jours
dans une petite auberge ayant attendu
toute sa vie un événement qui ne s'est
jamais produit
comment expliquer l’influence de ce
roman dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale en premier lieu son thème
principal le destin manqué est universel
les hommes espèrent souvent que des
événements extérieurs viennent donner un
sens à leur vie comme Drogo qui attend
l'attaque des ennemis du Nord les gens
attendent que leur travail leur relation
la gloire ou une forme d'accomplissement
personnel les gens ont tendance à
projeter leur épanouissement dans des
circonstances futures le désert des
tartares est donc une allégorie de la
quête infructueuse car passive de
bonheur et de sens
une autre raison de l’influence de ce
roman et sa saveur existentialiste bien
que budzati n'est pas cherché à écrire
un roman existentialiste le désert des
tartares est souvent associé au courant
de l'existentialisme et plutôt à raison
l'atmosphère d'absurdité qui émane du
récit et le message philosophique du
roman sont comme la signature de
l'existentialisme vous êtes qui était
d'ailleurs proche de Camus qui comme lui
et catégorisé comme un auteur
existentialiste alors qu'il n'a pas
lui-même revendiqué ou accepter
l'étiquette l'atmosphère et les thèmes
du Désert des Tartares font également
passer budzetti pour un héritier de
Kafka comme lui il décrit l'impuissance
humaine dans un monde incompréhensible
enfin en raison du thème spécial de
l'attente absurde le désert des Tartar
est parfois présenté sur le plan du
message philosophique comme l'équivalent
romanesque de la pièce de théâtre en
attendant Godot
enfin l'influence de ce roman dans la
littérature et la culture occidentale
tient également mais dans une moindre
mesure à la critique de la guerre
bootzati dépeint la monotonie et
l'absurdité qui imprègnent la vie
militaire dans l'attente du combat cela
me fait penser à ce que mon père me
disait à propos de son service militaire
j'ai appris à attendre le désert des
Tartar dissipe donc la vision romantique
de l'héroïsme militaire
[Musique]
16e référence
1984 de George Orwell je passe beaucoup
de temps sur Amazon je commande beaucoup
de livres mais je flâne aussi sur le
site et sur l'application comme je
flânais dans les librairies lorsque
j'habitais à Paris je regarde
attentivement les couvertures je lis les
présentations des éditeurs et les
commentaires si je fais la queue au
supermarché je sors mon téléphone pour
découvrir des livres sur l'application
Amazon lorsque j'écris un script pour
parler d'un livre particulier je passe
toujours un bon moment à comparer les
éditions sur Amazon pour ce roman je me
rends sur le site américain d'Amazon et
qu'est-ce que je vois près de 111000
notes avec une moyenne de 4, sur 5 et
plus de 10000 commentaires il a plus de
notes que la Bible ou que Harry Potter
j'ai décidé de commencer par vous parler
de ça parce que je n'ai jamais vu une
telle quantité de notes sur Amazon pour
un livre classique ni même pour un livre
tout court même si c'est vrai que je
m'intéresse peu aux nouveautés et du
coup par curiosité j'ai cherché un
classement des meilleurs ventes de tous
les temps sur Amazon et le résultat est
cohérent avec les 111000 notes 1984
d'Orwell et le 16e livre le plus vendu
de tous les temps sur Amazon
que ce roman classique de 1949 rivalise
commercialement avec Harry Potter et 50
nuances de Grey et révélateur il est
bien plus qu'un livre il est un symbole
important dans l'imaginaire collectif
occidentale
1984 est une référence littéraire
incontournable parce qu'il est et de
loin la plus célèbre dystopie jamais
écrite une dystopie ou contre utopie est
un récit de fiction qui dénonce les
travers d'une société imaginaire vous
connaissez peut-être également le
meilleur des mondes d'Aldous Huxley
Fahrenheit 451 de rebradbury ou encore
les monades urbaines de Robert
Silverberg mais ces romans n'ont pas
l'empreinte de 1984 sur la culture
occidentale pour faire simple 1984
symbolise la propagande et le
totalitarisme Apple c'est par exemple
servi du symbole qui est ce roman pour
sa légendaire pub de 1984 diffusée
pendant le Superbowl la finale du
championnat de football américain cette
pub montre une femme qui détruit un
écran géant l'instrument du
totalitarisme dans le roman avec un
marteau l'idée de la pub est que le
Macintosh d'Apple nous libère de la
conformité imposée par les autres
entreprises informatiques
sur le plan de la forme 1984 compte
entre 300 et 400 pages selon les
éditions le style d'Orwell est simple
direct sans ornement cette simplicité
incarne d'abord sa vision du langage
dans son essai politique NV englishling
Age la politique et la langue anglaise
en français dans cet essai Orwell
affirme je cite penser clairement et la
première étape nécessaire vers la
régénération politique or à ses yeux il
faut écrire clairement pour être capable
de penser clairement c'est une idée
profonde mais ce n'est pas du tout une
idée neuve les auteurs français de l'âge
classique avaient déjà mis en évidence
le lien entre la qualité de l'écriture
et la qualité de la pensée la simplicité
du style de 1984 sert également à
exprimer la monotonie et l'oppression de
la vie dans une société totalitaire
Orwell sort parfois de cette simplicité
pour refléter l'état émotionnel du héros
comme lorsque le héros écrit dans son
journal intime
je passe au résumé de l'histoire le
héros s'appelle Winston Smith il vit en
1984 dans un pays fictif dénommé
l'Océania ou l'État est totalitaire
comme dans les régimes totalitaires
historiques c'est le parti avec un grand
P et son leader Big Brother aussi appelé
le grand frère ou tonton dans certaines
traductions françaises ce sont le parti
unique et son chef qui ont la main sur
l'état Winston est employé au ministère
de la Vérité son métier consiste à
réécrire l'histoire afin qu'elle colle à
la propagande du parti
trois slogans régissent cette société
totalitaire la guerre c'est la paix la
liberté et c'est l'esclavage ce qui pour
le coup peut signifier quelque chose de
juste en philosophie par rapport à la
logique du désir humain dernier slogan
de la société totalitaire du roman
l'ignorance c'est la force cette idée-ci
est bien moins justifiable les autorités
entretiennent la haine de la population
envers Emmanuel Goldstein l'ennemi
public numéro 1 auteur d'un livre
subversif les autorités surveillent la
population à travers les télécran des
écrans installés dans presque tous les
espaces publics et privés et qui servent
à la fois de téléviseurs et de caméra
Winston a beau travailler pour le
système totalitaire il n'est pas un
mouton il se méfie du parti mais bien
sûr il ne peut pas exprimer ses doutes
écrire un journal intime et déjà un acte
de rébellion donc Winston écrit en
cachette avec la crainte perpétuelle
d'être découvert par la police de la
pensée
un jour Winston rencontre Julia elle lui
déplaît au début parce qu'il croit
qu'elle est une espionne du pouvoir mais
surprise elle lui glisse un mot où elle
a écrit je vous aime ils entame alors
une relation secrète et même une chambre
pour leur rendez-vous il partage la même
haine du parti alors que Winston
envisage une révolution Julia veut
simplement vivre sa vie ils sont
finalement découverts par le
propriétaire de la chambre qui était un
agent infiltré la police de la pensée
des arêtes
Winston et torturé au ministère de
l'amour par O'Brien O'Brien n'est pas
n'importe qui c'est un collègue membre
du Parti intérieur l’élite politique de
l'État totalitaire mais O'Brien s'était
présenté à Winston comme un
révolutionnaire il est en réalité un
membre loyal du parti chargé de traquer
les dissidents O'Brien rééduc Winston au
point de le faire trahir Julia mais à sa
libération Winston découvre que Julia et
lui se sont trahis mutuellement ce qui
détruit leur amour apprenant par la
propagande que l'armée vient d'obtenir
une victoire surprise Winston se met à
aimer Big Brother
la progression de l'histoire fait naître
une conviction chez le lecteur l'ennemi
public numéro un Goldstein pourrait bien
être une invention du parti lui-même
créée pour servir de bouc émissaires qui
focalise le mécontentement du peuple de
même le livre de Goldstein qui a révélé
à Winston les objectifs et les méthodes
du parti le livre subversif de Goldstein
pour être également être une fabrication
destinée à attraper ceux qui pensent de
manière subversive le roman laisse cette
question ouverte
maintenant comment résumer
l'exceptionnel influence de 1984 sur la
littérature et la culture occidentale je
vais me limiter aux trois dimensions de
cette influence qui me paraissent les
plus essentielles sur le plan de la
littérature tout d'abord 1984 popularise
le genre dystopique et sert de modèle
dans ce genre il pose des conventions
narratives que reprendront les auteurs
ultérieurs du genre notamment la
description d'un pouvoir politique qui
voit tout qui pratique la désinformation
et qui répriment la pensée non conforme
il lance également des thèmes clés du
genre dystopique moderne comme la
manipulation du langage ou la
déshumanisation des individus dans un
régime totalitaire
[Musique]
les deux autres dimensions essentielles
de l’influence de 1984 concerne son
message politique il y a d'abord la
question de la surveillance Big Brother
est devenu le symbole de la surveillance
de masse par l'État et plus profondément
de la disparition de la vie privée à
l'époque d'Orwell les autorités ne
pouvaient surveiller leur population en
faisant un usage exacerbé de
l'espionnage comme en Allemagne de l'Est
lors de la guerre froide où on estime
qu'un citoyens sur 100 était un
formateur pour la police politique mais
les technologies disponibles en 2023
sont désormais supérieurs aux télé-écran
imaginé par Orwell et qui sait ce que
l'avenir nous réserve
la troisième dimension essentielle de
l'influence de 1984 concerne la
propagande Orwell évoque les techniques
de base comme le culte de la
personnalité mais les techniques
avancées de conditionnement décrites
dans le roman montrent que la propagande
vise ultimement le contrôle de la pensée
les deux techniques emblématiques du
roman ce sont la manipulation de la
langue et la réécriture de l'histoire
concernant la langue Orwell imagine que
l'État totalitaire impose une nouvelle
langue la novlangue qui rendent
impossible l'expression d'idées
subversive cette novlang repose sur
l'hypothèse selon laquelle ce qu'on peut
dire la langue détermine ce qu'on peut
penser c'est-à-dire que les
représentations mentales dépendent des
catégories linguistiques
le terme novlang est entré dans le
vocabulaire courant pour qualifier une
expression ou un discours qui dissimule
ou trahit la réalité en mélant la langue
de bois et le politiquement correct par
exemple un responsable politique peut
qualifier de dialogues constructifs des
négociations qui n'ont en réalité abouti
à rien
concernant la seconde technique de
propagande emblématique du roman la
réécriture de l'histoire Orwell imagine
que l'État totalitaire profite de son
contrôle des archives pour retoucher
voir détruire le passé ça ce n'est pas
de la fiction j'ai par exemple lu dans
la biographie de Staline que lorsqu'il
se débarrassait d'un membre de l'élite
soviétique il faisait modifier les
encyclopédie de l'URSS aux ciseaux et à
la colle afin de minimiser le rôle de
l'individu en question dans l'histoire
de l'URSS voire de supprimer son
existence dans la mémoire collective qui
commande le passé écrit en well en 1984
commande l'avenir qui commande le
présent commande le passé cette forme
exacerbée de propagande met en évidence
deux idées intéressantes mais
controversées à propos de l'histoire
première idée l'histoire est écrite par
les gagnants par les hommes qui
détiennent le pouvoir seconde idée
intéressante le passé n'existe pas dans
l'absolu indépendamment d'un biais
d'interprétation ce serait le même
phénomène qu'à l'échelle individuelle
les souvenirs ne sont pas objectifs
parce que la mémoire transforme la
réalité passée
voilà pour les deux dimensions du
message politique de 1984 ce sont ces
deux dimensions la surveillance et la
propagande qui donne son second sens à
l'adjectif orwellien dans son premier
sens il fait simplement référence à
Orwell et à son œuvre on peut par
exemple dire la langue orwellienne mais
c'est aujourd'hui le second sens de
l'adjectif qui est bien plus courant une
société qualifiée d'orwellienne est une
société dans laquelle les autorités
contrôlent la population grâce à la
surveillance et à la propagande certains
disent que les sociétés occidentales du
21e siècle peuvent devenir véritablement
orwellienne voir qu'elles sont en train
de le devenir c'est par exemple la thèse
de l'écrivain controversé Laurent
auberton dans la France Big Brother j'ai
pour ma part l'impression que la
dimension chaotique des grandes sociétés
démocratiques et que les innombrables
résistances que rencontrent les
autorités politiques dans la réalité
concrète de l’exercice de leur pouvoir
cela rend compliqué d'installer un
totalitarisme à la 1984
17e référence l'Attrape-Coeur JD
Salinger
réussir à percer et particulièrement
difficile pour un écrivain donc
lorsqu'un auteur réussit enfin à vivre
de sa plume et à obtenir la
reconnaissance du public il est au moins
soulagé les jours de galère sont
derrière lui mais Jérôme David Salinger
qu'on abrait usuellement en JD Salinger
est un écrivain allergique à la
célébrité sa vie change à 32 ans lorsque
ce roman devient un best-seller il ne
peut plus mener une vie normale à New
York donc il déménage dans un état rural
à plusieurs centaines de kilomètres au
nord de la capitale culturelle des
États-Unis dans une petite ville de 1500
habitants il y vivra reclus loin de
toute exposition médiatique et étant
donné la logique du désir humain ce
choix d’être inaccessible fera de lui un
auteur mythique
mais pourquoi ce roman est-il
incontournable dans la littérature et la
culture occidentale parce qu'il
symbolise la crise d'adolescence il est
également emblématique du fait que les
questions liées à l'adolescence comme la
rébellion contre l'autorité et
l'exploration de l'identité ces
questions deviennent des thèmes
culturels fertiles à partir des années
1950 le roman paraît en 1951 bien sûr
ces thèmes s'inscrivent dans la
révolution culturelle occidentale des
trentes glorieuses des hommes réputés
rigides comme Georges Bush senior ou
Bill Gates cite ce roman pour paraître
plus ouvert d'esprit enfin c'est ce que
moi je soupçonne
le titre de ce roman renvoie
indirectement au mal-être adolescent
pour le comprendre il faut analyser le
titre anglais The catcher in the rise
the catcher c'est celui qui attrape
l'intercepteur le gardien le Sauveur the
rail c'est le seigle la céréale
résistante au froid qui sert à faire du
pain et du whisky et every peut
également désigner un champ de seigle
donc the catcher in the rail c'est le
gardien du champ de seigle cette image
est issue d'une chanson enfantine
populaire le protagoniste du roman
entend cette chanson et il fantasme sur
le fait de sauver de jeunes enfants qui
jouent dans un champ de seigle près d'un
précipice c'est une métaphore le
précipice symbolise la corruption du
monde adulte et le désir d'empêcher les
enfants de tomber dans le précipice
symbolise le désir de préserver
l'innocence de l'enfance de l'hypocrisie
du monde adulte l'image du champ de
seigle est difficile voire impossible à
retranscrire en français donc le
traducteur il y a substitué l'image du
cœur
sur le plan de la forme ce roman en
compte 250 300 pages selon les éditions
c'est facile à lire parce que sa linger
simule la langue parlée d'un adolescent
américain du début des trentes
glorieuses c'est un peu l'argot des ados
du coup il y a des tics de langage des
mots approximatifs et des tournures
familières ce qui a surtout marqué le
public à l'époque c'est la crudité du
langage qui en plus du caractère
controversé de certains thèmes évoqués
comme la prostitution et la drogue la
crudité du langage a contribué à
l'interdiction du livre dans des
établissements scolaires le style n'est
donc pas littéraire mais presque basique
l'adolescence adresse directement au
lecteurs cet écrit à la première
personne du singulier il y a beaucoup de
phrases courtes
maintenant quelle est l'essentiel à
retenir concernant l'histoire
l'Attrape-Coeur raconte la fugue de
Holden callfield un fils de la
bourgeoisie new-yorkaise de 17 ans
chasser de son collège trois jours avant
Noël il n'ose pas rentrer chez lui et y
affronter ses parents il va Gabon de
donc pendant 3 jours le premier jour il
se fâche avec son colocataire et prend
le train pour New York son internat est
à quelques centaines de kilomètres à
l'ouest à New York il loge dans un hôtel
miteux il fait une virée nocturne
solitaire bar alcool femme
insignifiantes il pose une question
qu'il obsède à un chauffeur de taxi où
les canards de Central Park vont-ils une
fois que le lac est gelé cette obsession
est une métaphore célèbre du fait que
l'adolescent se sente enfermé dans un
monde qui n'est pas fait pour lui de
retour à l'hôtel Holden refuse les
avances d'une prostituée ce qui lui vaut
une altercation avec son proxénète la
nuit se termine sur des pensées
suicidaires
après son histoire avec le proxénète
Holden quitte l'hôtel le deuxième jour
il achète un disque pour sa soeur et
c'est en se rendant à la boutique qu'il
entend la chanson qui donne son titre au
roman ensuite il va voir une pièce de
théâtre avec une fille de son internat
le rendez-vous tourne mal il se dispute
Holden rentre chez lui et par chance ses
parents sont absents il a cassé le
cadeau pour sa sœur en errant dans
Central Park mais il lui donne quand
même il passe la nuit chez son ancien
prof d'anglais mais il se réveille
lorsqu'ils sont une main sur sa tête et
voit son prof assis juste à côté de lui
traumatisé par les pédophiles qui l'a
croisé au cours de sa vie il s'enfuit
Holden passe la fin de la nuit à la gare
il demande à sa sœur de le retrouver au
musée pour des adieux elle vient valise
en main pour s'enfuir dans l'Ouest avec
lui mais finalement Holden décide de ne
pas partir il offre un tour de manège à
sa soeur on découvre à ce moment golden
est en hôpital psychiatrique et
l'histoire convient de lire et
probablement ce qui la raconté à un
professionnel de l'hôpital
comment résumer l'influence de ce roman
dans la littérature et la culture
occidentale tout d'abord il apporte un
nouveau souffle au genre du roman
d'apprentissage pour rappel un roman
d'apprentissage est une histoire qui
suit le développement moral
psychologique ou social vers la maturité
d'un personnage principal généralement
de la jeunesse à l'âge adulte à travers
une série d'expériences et d'épreuves
mais alors que les romans
d’apprentissage classique suivent une
trajectoire linéaire l'Attrape-Coeur est
plus ambigu le personnage de Salinger ne
trouve pas de réponse simple à ces
questions existentielles il demeure en
conflit avec lui-même et avec le monde
qui l'entoure jusqu'à la fin il est un
des premiers anti-héros adolescents de
la littérature moderne
seconde raison de l’influence de ce
roman il symbolise la crise
d'adolescence Holden est un être très
sensible qui ne veut pas se compromettre
avec la société mais il faut dézoomer
pour comprendre son comportement après
la Seconde Guerre mondiale les
adolescents commencent à être considérés
comme un groupe social distinct
concrètement ils sont plus visibles
parce qu'ils représentent un groupe de
consommateurs à part avec ses propres
goûts culturels et surtout avec
désormais un pouvoir d'achat car la
prospérité permet aux parents de gâter
leurs enfants d'ailleurs le héros du
roman fugue avec l'argent de ces riches
parents l'Attrape-Coeur est un peu à la
littérature ce qu'est la fureur de vivre
avec l'adolescent turbulent incarné par
James Dean au cinéma
[Musique]
18e référence le vieil homme et la mer
Ernest Hemingway au début des années
1950 le journaliste américain James
Michener étant en Corée pour couvrir la
guerre un jour alors qu'il n'est pas
loin des combats un homme lui remet
rapidement une enveloppe le magazine
Life qui est un des plus diffusé aux
États-Unis où il est une véritable
institution culturelle le magazine Life
demande à James Michener de préfacer un
nouveau roman bien sûr il doit d'abord
le lire il se plonge donc dedans et il
dira plus tard qu'il n'entendait plus
les obus passés au dessus de sa tête il
n'était plus à la guerre en Corée mais à
Cuba à la pêche avec un vieil homme
ce roman est incontournable parce qu'il
représente la révolution du style qui se
produit au milieu du 20e siècle pour
faire simple Hemingway adapte la prose
romanesque à la culture de masse son
style qui réussit à être profond tout en
étant minimaliste et direct le rend
accessible à un large public il reçoit
le prix Nobel de littérature en 1954 je
cite pour le style puissant et nouveau
par lequel il maîtrisait l'art de la
narration moderne comme vient de le
prouver le vieil homme et la mer l'année
précédente ce roman avait déjà valu à
Hemingway le prix Pulitzer l'une des
récompenses les plus prestigieuses aux
États-Unis on peut également dire que le
vieil homme et la mer est un roman
emblématique de la démocratisation de la
littérature aux États-Unis le pays qui
produit la culture dominante en Occident
à partir de la seconde moitié du 20e
siècle
concernant la forme c'est un des romans
les plus courts qui est jamais reçu
certains des prix littéraires les plus
prestigieux autour de 130 140 pages
selon les éditions comme je viens de le
dire la prose est très simple la plupart
des phrases sont courtes et leur
structure n'est jamais compliquée et
mingway se permet même des choses que
les manuels de style déconseillent à
raison comme des répétitions de mots
d'une phrase à l'autre ou l'accumulation
des et qui ne fait pas terrible à la
lecture je trouve mais il crée des
images puissantes rendus d'autant plus
puissantes par le contraste avec le
minimalisme de la prose voici par
exemple comment il décrit le vieil homme
au début du roman tout en lui était
vieux à l'exception de ses yeux qui
avait la couleur de la mer et qui était
joyeuse et invaincu
Hemingway a élaboré une théorie pour
expliquer la puissance de son style
minimaliste la théorie de l'iceberg
selon cette théorie une histoire est
comme un iceberg seul la pointe est
rendue visible par la prose mais il y a
beaucoup plus en dessous un style à la
fois simple et précis permettent au
lecteurs de plonger plus profondément
pour découvrir les couches cachées de
sens
maintenant je vous résume rapidement
l'intrigue l'histoire se passe à Cuba ou
Hemingway a longtemps vécu y compris
pendant la Révolution Cubaine qui
s'étend de 1953 à 1959 le vieil homme du
titre est le pêcheur Santiago il est ami
avec un jeune garçon Manolin qui est son
partenaire de pêche mais après 84 jours
sans prise maintenant il doit quitter
son Tiago pour un bateau plus chanceux
cela ne l'empêche pas de continuer
d'aider son ancien partenaire il répare
les filets du vieil homme et partage ses
repas avec lui voulant en temps finir
avec sa malchance le vieil homme et
décide de tenter sa chance loin dans le
golf
le 85e jour il accroche un énorme Marlin
on trouve ce poisson puissant dans les
autres picales il est un peu un trophée
ultime dans la pêche sportive les
pêcheurs du Golfe du Mexique qui sépare
Miami et Cuba rêvent de capturer ce
poisson légendaire d'ailleurs l'équipe
de baseball de Miami s'appelle les
Marlins de Miami
je reviens au roman la lutte entre
l'énorme Marlin et le vieil homme est
épique trois jours durant Santiago en
dure la fin la soif et la douleur il
parle même à son adversaire qu'il
respecte il parvient finalement à le
tuer mais il y a un souci il ne parvient
pas à hisser l'énorme Marlin à bord de
sa petite barque ce produit alors ce qui
symbolise les revers de fortune les
requins se pressent autour de la petite
barque le vieil homme se défend contre
leurs attaques répétées malgré son
extrême fatigue grâce à leur nombre les
requins finissent par dévorer le marlin
il ne reste plus que la tête que le
vieil homme ramène au port en guise de
trophée son ancien partenaire le jeune
Manolin est impressionné il décide de
revenir pêcher avec le vieil homme
comment résumer l'influence de ce roman
il y a tout d'abord l'originalité du
style que j'ai déjà évoqué la prose
épurée d'Hemingway est un nouveau modèle
qui correspond à l'évolution du public
occidental et qui inspirera beaucoup de
romanciers comme l'avait anticipé Jack
London au début du 20e siècle la
production et la consommation de masse
pousse à la simplification du style et à
l'économie de mots le rôle emblématique
des mingway dans cette évolution
illustre aussi l'influence de la presse
et du journaliste sur le genre
romanesque quelque part les romanciers
se mettent à écrire comme des
journalistes
une autre dimension essentielle de
l’influence de ce roman et sa métaphore
de la condition humaine le destin du
vieux pêcheur cubain est une allégorie
de la bravoure et de la volonté humaine
vaincu mais non détruite par les forces
meurtrières de la nature la plus célèbre
citation du roman est un homme ça peut
être détruit mais pas vaincu la morale
est simple la sagesse est réside dans
l'humilité
enfin une autre dimension essentielle de
l'influence de ce roman et qu'il
revalorise le potentiel esthétique de la
nature et plus particulièrement de la
relation de l'homme à la nature c'est le
premier livre que j'ai accepté de lire
sur la recommandation de mon père qui
est un passionné de pêche certains
lecteurs trouvent que l'histoire est
trop ennuyeuse mais les personnes
sensibles à la beauté de la nature en
particulier de la mer les personnes qui
ont déjà pris du plaisir à pêcher ou un
naviguer peuvent retrouver ce plaisir en
se plongeant dans le vieil homme et la
mer
[Musique]
19ème référence Lolita de Vladimir
Nabokov
ce roman a été écrit en anglais et
publié pour la première fois en français
mais attendez Vladimir nabocov ça sonne
quand même franchement russe
effectivement l'auteur est bien russe
mais pas n'importe quel russe il est le
rejeton d'une riche famille de la
noblesse russe donc il n'a pas été
éduqué à l'école publique du quartier
alors qu'il a 6 ans sa famille passe un
bref séjour à la campagne et là son père
découvre quelque chose qui heurte
profondément sa sensibilité de patriote
russe Vladimir et son frère sont
capables de lire et d'écrire en anglais
mais pas en russe en fait ce n'est pas
étonnant parce que ce sont des
préceptrices anglaises et qui éduquent
ses fils au quotidien dans l'hôtel
particulier de la famille à
Saint-Pétersbourg cette éducation
ultra privilégiée donnera à Vladimir
d'abocov une telle aisance avec la
langue anglaise qui l'écrira lui un
russe dont la famille a fui l'URSS un
des plus grands chefs-d'œuvre de la
littérature américaine
mais ce n'est pas ça qui rend ce roman
incontournable lolita est célèbre parce
qu'il est un des romans les plus
scandaleux sinon le plus scandaleux de
la littérature occidentale en effet son
thème touche à un interdit
anthropologique la pédophilie c'est ce
qu'il représente dans la littérature et
la culture occidentale une histoire
d'amour pédophile le scandale et
l'influence de ce roman ont été tels que
son titre est devenu un nom commun c'est
ce qu'on appelle une antonomase la
figure de style qui consiste à se servir
d'un nom propre comme d'un nom commun ou
inversement une lolita c'est une
pré-adolescente sexualisée par le regard
d'un homme mûr d'ailleurs ce roman a
popularisé un autre terme qui désigne la
même chose la nymphette formée à partir
de nymphes qui désigne une jeune fille
gracieuse en référence aux divinités
féminines de la mythologie grecque et du
suffixe est qui signifie que la chose
est plus petite
concernant la forme il y en a pour plus
de 500 pages dans la version française
donc c'est quand même pour les courageux
le parfum de scandale et le caractère
contemporain de l'histoire est à
conserver l'attention du lecteur
seulement le style de Nabokov risque de
rebuter un lecteur qui n'est pas un fan
de littérature certes n'abocov écrit
très bien mais souvent trop bien c'est à
dire avec une sophistication excessive
lorsque j'ai lu ce roman il y a 15 ans
je tenais un petit carnet dans lequel je
notais les mots que je n'étais pas
capable de définir précisément à la
lecture et bien je n'ai pas arrêté
d'ajouter de nouveaux termes en avançant
dans Lolita Nabokov se sert de mots
rares et précis notamment pour décrire
le physique de la pré-adolescente et
l'obsession de l'homme mûr en plus de
l’excessive richesse du vocabulaire les
phrases sont longues et structurées de
manière compliquée les paragraphes aussi
sont parfois longs enfin les nombreuses
allusions ou références culturelles
notamment littéraire complique encore la
tâche en conclusion c'est de la
littérature de haut niveau qui demande
un certain effort de lecture
je passe au résumé de l'intrigue le
livre se présente comme la longue
confession rédigée par un meurtrier
avant son procès un dénommé Humbert
comme il est mort dans infarctus
quelques jours avant le début du procès
un ami de l'avocat a pris l'initiative
de publier la confession un beurre
l'auteur de cette confession est donc
narrateur est né à Paris en 1910 prof de
littérature il est un homme séduisant il
est conscient de s'attirance pour les
jeunes filles qui l’appellent les
nymphettes après son divorce il quitte
l'Europe pour les États-Unis où il peut
hériter d'un oncle cherchant un lieu
calme pour étudier il prend une chambre
chez une femme qui a une fille de 12 ans
c'est justement la vue de cette
nymphette en train de bronzer sur la
pelouse qu'il a décidé à loger dans la
maison car elle lui rappelle une amie de
13 ans qu'il avait aimé passionnément
lorsqu'il avait lui-même 13 ans là le
narrateur donne une justification
psychanalytique à son attirance pour les
pré-adolescentes
il fait tout pour se rapprocher de la
fille de sa logeuse qu'il surnomme
Lolita mais c'est la mère qui tombe
amoureuse de lui alors il accepte de
l'épouser pour rester près de la fille
seulement sa nouvelle femme découvre son
journal intime où elle apprend qu'elle
le dégoûte et que sa fille la tire elle
s'enfuit alors pour le dénoncer mais
elle est tuée par une voiture en
traversant la rue un père devient donc
le tuteur de Lolita il va la récupérer
au camp de vacances en lui faisant
croire qu'il l'a conduit auprès de sa
mère hospitalisée il passe la nuit à
l'hôtel et ils ont leur premier rapport
le matin suivant à l'initiative de
Lolita d'après le narrateur c'est
seulement après qui lui apprend la mort
de sa mère
ensuite il voyage pendant un an dans les
États-Unis ce qui permet un avocoop de
décrire l'Amérique des années 1940 il
demeure quelques mois dans une ville
moyenne où Lolita retourne au collège la
jalousie de Imbert crée de nombreuses
disputes ils reprennent la route et au
cours de ce nouveau voyage Lolita
s'enfuit avec un amant du même âge qu'un
verre il la cherche partout mais au bout
de trois ans il renonce il a finalement
de ses nouvelles par une lettre elle lui
écrit qu'elle est mariée et enceinte et
elle lui demande de l'argent afin de
s'installer avec son mari il se rend
chez elle mais comme le mari n'est pas
l'homme qui lui a volé entre guillemets
Lolita et comme celle-ci repousse ses
avances Imbert lui donne de l'argent et
repart le cœur brisé mais il a quand
même réussi à lui soutirer le nom de
l'amant avec lequel elle était partie
alors il le retrouve et le tue de
plusieurs balles c'est pour ce meurtre
qu'il est en prison où il livre sa
confession
je vous parle maintenant des dimensions
essentielles de l'influence de ce roman
sur le plan littéraire la narration est
innovante Nabokov crée un narrateur qui
manipule le lecteur comme il manipule
les autres personnages imber veut faire
croire que c'est lolita qui l'attirent à
elle et qu'il ne s'agit pas de
pédophilie si on ne saisit pas cette
spécificité de la narration alors on
voit le roman comme une apologie de la
pédophilie alors que Nabokov répète
lui-même dans la préface que son roman
n'est pas cela certains critiques ont
par exemple résumé le livre en disant la
virtuosité littéraire au service de la
pédophilie mais bon c'est vrai que
l'innovation narrative de navocov est
subtile et donc certains lecteurs se
font effectivement manipulés par le
narrateur
sur le plan littéraire ce roman est
également emblématique d'un refus de la
tendance dominante à la simplification
de la prose
sur le plan plus largement culturel
Lolita incarne la transgression de la
morale sociale le manuscrit a été refusé
par les éditeurs américains qui
craignaient d'être ruinés par les
poursuites judiciaires puis censurer en
France un an après sa sortie mais le
scandale est toujours vendeur plus de
100000 exemplaires écoulés en seulement
3 semaines lorsqu'il paraît enfin aux
États-Unis comme les éditeurs
comprennent le potentiel financier de la
controverse il est mis sur des
couvertures suggestives le célèbre
réalisateur Stanley Kubrick reprendra la
même recette 7 ans après l'apparition du
roman à Paris pour son adaptation
cinématographique l'affiche du film
présente une jeune fille aux lunettes en
cœur et une sucette à la bouche
20e référence sur la route de Jacques
Kerouac
c'est ce roman qui m'a donné envie de
voyager à la fin de l'adolescence et je
ne suis pas le seul je me souviens d'une
conversation avec un jeune ingénieur
australien et ses amis dans une piscine
à Las Vegas eux aussi avaient été
inspirés par ce livre donc ils avaient
loué une voiture pour reproduire les
voyages racontés par Jacques Kerouac et
ils sont nombreux les jeunes occidentaux
à avoir eu cette idée car ce roman est à
l'origine du mythe du road trip
Adventure sur la route ou voyage en
voiture en français un road triple ça
consiste à partir sur la route sans
itinéraires précis pour explorer de
nouveaux lieux rencontrer de nouvelles
personnes et vivre des expériences
inédites c'est le voyage lui-même qui
est important par la destination
mais l'influence de ce roman ne se
résume pas à cela en effet le road trip
symbolise plus généralement la rupture
avec le mode de vie confortable
prévisible et insipide de l'homme
ordinaire de la société de consommation
occidentale à cet égard sur la route
annonce la révolution culturelle des
années 1960 parce que c'est héros sont
de jeunes occidentaux qui sacrifient
leur conformes matériels pour vivre des
expériences significatives sur la route
et plus précisément le roman
emblématique de la generation le
mouvement culturel des années 1950 à
l'origine de la culture hippie des
années 1960 la liberté est
l'anticonformisme qui émanent de
l'histoire fascineront des générations
de jeunes lecteurs jusqu'à aujourd'hui
sur le plan de la forme ce livre compte
entre 300 et 400 pages selon les
éditions il est accessible même pour un
lecteur de 2023 le style est simple et
fluide parce que Kerouac a écrit le
roman sous l'emprise de stupéfiants en
seulement 3 semaines ce qui fera dire à
Truman Capote un autre grand romancier
américain que ce n'est pas de l'écriture
mais de la dactylographique l'autre
anecdote célèbre c'est que Kerouac a
écrit la première version du roman sur
un rouleau de papier attaché de 36
mètres c'est un choix original drôle et
même mythique mais cela n'a pas disposé
les éditeurs à accepter le manuscrit en
termes d'expérience de lecture cela crée
une sensation de flux continu la
fluidité du style de Kerouac est
originale parce qu'il combine de manière
hachée des phrases longues et abruptes
ce style spécial s'inspire à la fois du
rythme d'improvisation du jazz et de la
poésie traditionnelle japonaise les
haïku
je passe au résumé de l'intrigue le
roman raconte les voyages à travers les
États-Unis de deux amis salle le
narrateur et alterego fictif de Jacques
Kerouac et DIN l'alter ego fictif de
l'écrivain nail casadi sale commence par
raconter leur rencontre à New York tout
juste sortie d'une école pour jeune
délinquant digne vient découvrir la vie
culturelle de New York sa folie fascine
sale et stimule son désir d'aventure DIN
rentre à Denver sa ville natale au
centre des États-Unis puissale le
rejoint en auto-stop et en bus ce qui
lui permet de rencontrer d'autres
marginaux sur la route réunies à Denver
les deux amis assouvissent leur passion
commune faire la fête boire et se
droguer
ensuite salle quitte dîne pour la
Californie il y vit avec un vieil ami
puis à une brève histoire d'amour avec
une femme d'origine mexicaine qui
travaille avec lui dans les champs de
coton après la Californie salle retrouve
sa vie à New York
bien retrouvé salle dans la maison de sa
famille à Noël il part alors ensemble
dans la voiture de Dean pour rendre
visite à un mentor toxicoman à la
Nouvelle-Orléans il traverse ensuite le
Texas et l'Arizona il longe le sud des
États-Unis il vole de l'essence et de la
nourriture au fur et à mesure de leurs
besoins jusqu'à ce qu'ils atteignent
enfin San Francisco Dean préfère vivre
avec sa femme donc il quitte sale mais
il se retrouve pour se saouler dans les
clubs de jazz de San Francisco
finalement salle fatiguée et ruiné par
ses voyages retourne une nouvelle fois à
New York
ensuite salve commencer une nouvelle vie
à Denver mais comme il n'y parvient pas
il part rejoindre son groupe d'amis à
San Francisco Dean essaie mener une vie
de famille normale à l'arrivée de salles
il redevient fou ce qui contre un sa
femme à le mettre à la porte les deux
amis veulent aller en Italie mais
d'abord il passe des nuits à boire et à
ce droguer dans les clubs de jazz de San
Francisco puis rebelote à Denver les
pulsions de délinquance de Dean les
forces à quitté la ville ils font les
chauffeurs pour un homme jusqu’à Chicago
d'où après bien sûr avoir fait la fête
dans les clubs de jazz de la ville de
Chicago ils reviennent à New York dans
cette ville digne est une femme enceinte
les deux amis ne verront jamais l'Italie
ils sont ensuite attirés par le sud
laissant femmes et enfants à New York
dînent part en voiture avec salle et un
troisième larron direction le Mexique
ils sont fascinés par la culture et la
liberté qu'offre ce pays sur le chemin
jusqu'à la capitale il s'arrête dans de
petites villes où il trouve de la drogue
et des prostituées à villeprix à Mexico
salle contracte la dysenterie une
maladie qui cause des diarrhées sévères
donc dinyles une fois rétablie ça leur
rentre à New York il découvre que DIN y
a épousé la femme qu'il y avait laissé
puis qu'il l'a quitter pour retrouver sa
femme précédente à San Francisco
le livre se termine par un voyage de dyn
à New York sale et désespérée par le
désordre et les ennuis liés à son mode
de vie mais la folie de Dine l'inspire
toujours seulement il ne peut plus le
suivre à San Francisco c'est la dernière
fois qu'il se voit
maintenant comment résumer l'influence
de ce roman sur le plan littéraire il
révolutionne le style narratif Kerouac
baptise sa technique d'écriture prose
spontanée comme le nom l'indique il
s'agit de laisser les mots couler
spontanément et librement sans s'arrêter
pour se corriger ou se censurer c'est le
contraire de la méthode de la plupart
des grands romanciers classiques qui
passent beaucoup de temps à retravailler
leurs prose au contraire la prose
spontanée de Kerouac demande à
l'écrivain de capturer ses pensées et
ses expériences sous une forme brute
l'intérêt de cette méthode est qu'elle
décuple la créativité dans l’écriture
sans parler du fait qu'elle économise
beaucoup de temps et d'efforts elle
inspirera des auteurs phares de la
Révolution culturelle comme Allonnes
Ginsberg ou le journaliste Hunter
Thompson
sur le plan plus largement culturel sur
la route et le manifeste du mouvement de
la generation donc erwock est le
chef de fil l'anglais qui signifie
battement rythme renvoie à 4 idées la
tradition des vagabondes des trains de
marchandises qui sévissaient au 19e
siècle aux États-Unis tradition
notamment décrite par Jack London dans
les vagabonds du rail deuxième idée à
laquelle renvoie l'anglais bit le fait
d'être abattu par le conformisme social
de l'époque troisième idée le battement
du cœur et enfin quatrième idée le
rythme musical du jazz dont les deux
amis du roman salle Eddine sont fans en
tant que manifeste de la génération
sur la route préfigure le mouvement
hippie et la révolution culturelle des
trentes glorieuses cela en fait
également un symbole de la remise en
cause du rêve américain et plus
généralement du mode de vie sédentaire
générique de la classe moyenne
occidentale
enfin ce roman a encore influencé la
culture occidentale de deux manières
plus spécifiques il a lancé le mythe du
road trip comme je l'ai dit au début il
a également joué un rôle significatif
dans la mythologie de San Francisco
comme une ville d'aventure de liberté et
de contre-culture elle abrite toujours
la librairie et maison d'édition
emblématiques de la generation city
lights qui a notamment édité des poèmes
de Kerouac il y a même un musée dédié à
la generation le beat Museum et une
allée Jacques Kerouac
si vous aimez l'esprit de cette vidéo à
savoir à découvrir des choses
intéressantes en allant à l'essentiel et
sans se prendre la tête alors vous
aimerez probablement mon programme
Culture Express c'est un programme
méthodique pour devenir facilement une
personne cultivée en seulement quelques
mois il couvre tous les domaines de la
culture générale vous maîtriserez les
connaissances essentielles sur
l'histoire de l'humanité sur l'histoire
de France en économie en sciences
politiques en psychologie en sciences en
littérature en art en religion et en
philosophie vous ne serez plus jamais à
court de choses à dire et vous gagnerez
la confiance nécessaire pour briller en
toute circonstances vous pouvez en
savoir plus en cliquant sur le lien qui
s'affiche en haut à droite ou bien sur
celui qui est dans la description ou
bien encore en tapant directement
l'adresse qui s'affiche à l'écran dans
la barre de recherche et je pense que la
meilleure façon de vous donner une idée
du programme et d'écouter ce que les
membres ont à en dire Valentine et qui
reconnaît l'énorme quantité de travail
que ce programme a représenté pour moi
dit je cite que c'est une véritable mine
d'or l'essentiel est là tout est simple
pratique très bien expliqué concentré il
n'y a plus qu'à recopier et à apprendre
ce travail est vraiment formidable et
passionnant Maxence mécré directement
dans les commentaires en dessous d'une
vidéo du programme la formation est
vraiment remarquable j'étais un peu
dubitatif étant donné le prix initial
mais je ne regrette pas c'est un vrai
travail de synthèse que tu nous proposes
et le format vidéo est très adapté pour
moi qui est une mémoire essentiellement
auditive le choix des thèmes et des
chapitres et pertinents et je trouve que
tu as trouvé la dose d'approfondissement
parfaite à la fois précis mais sans
fioriture vincent lui fait carrément ma
pub j'ai d'ailleurs recommandé votre
formation à ma sœur qui travaille comme
diplomate la semaine dernière elle a
déjà eu l'occasion de mettre à profit
dans ses discussions les connaissances
que vous avez diffusées vous verrez
d'autres témoignages comme ceci dans les
commentaires si vous rejoignez le
programme et si vous vous inscrivez vous
bénéficiez d'une garantie résultat une
fois que vous aurez terminé le programme
je vous rembourserai intégralement si
vous estimez que vous n'avez pas acquis
une solide culture générale si vous
voulez en savoir plus cliquez sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite ou
bien sur celui qui est dans la
description ou bien encore taper
directement l'adresse qui s'affiche à
l'écran dans la barre de recherche plus
de 800 membres ont déjà tiré parti de ce
programme et je serai ravi qu'il en soit
de même pour vous dans tous les cas
j'espère que la vidéo vous a plu je suis
romain et vous vous étiez sur 1000 idées
de culture générale rappelez-vous vous
n'avez pas besoin de vous prendre la
tête pour vous intéresser au meilleur de
la pensée
[Musique]